netflix was like where do you want to do
the special la chicago new york i was
like nah son davis california
[Applause]
[Music]
what's a day for you like
uh
because you're you're completely free
now right i'm completely free well
you're never really freaked out you know
you build a prison of your own making
now
yeah so you know two little kids a day
starts with morning shift dad duty yes i
take the mornings i got a two-year-old
and an eight-month-old yeah and so
we're like we're the same like yeah you
were talking about it yesterday i was
like i feel ya yeah
and we so i do the morning shift that's
just straight dad time then i basically
pick between
i got three kind of major projects yeah
so i got um investing so sometimes we'll
be looking at deals then it's um could
be content but content is really kind of
on a specific niche schedule it's like
monday wednesday for an hour we sit down
we do the show and that's kind of it i
don't do too much more than that i write
sometimes and like twitter emails or
whatever and then i have a business so
me and my wife started an e-commerce
business oh cool and so that that scaled
up so basically in the last year
that went from zero
like just an idea yeah to now we do like
over a million dollars a month of
revenue on that business i was looking
for something new yeah that i could do
as a side hustle something that wasn't
like yeah gonna take up all my time yeah
but could still be a valuable business
that was uh you know like some part-time
basically yeah and so that's what have
you always been like that multiple
hustles have you always been that guy
i was always that guy they weren't
working before so
really i was trying to do that and i was
failing at it and like since high school
like you were that dude so no so so a
lot of people have this story a lot of
entrepreneurs have this like
oh back in i was my lemonade stand i was
selling i was doing newspaper routes and
i hired all these kids yeah baseball
cars i was due the lights were off in my
head until like 21 so like i was like
i'm gonna be pre-med i was gonna be i
wanted to be a team doctor for an nba
team so yeah okay what do i do i wanted
to be on the nba team all right genetics
not working yeah team doctor that seems
like yeah my genetics and like my
interest yeah and only when i met a team
doctor i was like wow this is boring as
[__] like you're just like you know
these are just joints that are in pain
and there's only so much you could do
it's like not as exciting i need a plan
b i was 21 when i figured that out wow
and i was like you were still an
undergrad yeah i had just taken mcats i
was ready to go to med school i was like
uh what else i had this random business
idea with a couple buddies that sounded
kind of silly it was so silly that it
was almost like not dangerous you know
how that is like yeah sometimes
a very serious sounding idea is almost
too intimidating to do but this almost
seems so goofy it was harmless i'm just
gonna go try i'm just gonna do this but
yeah obviously i'll eventually go to med
school yeah obviously i was like i'm not
gonna
you know i just and you're doing this
for a couple months also
um you're at a point in your life
college is so unique in the sense that
you you're leaning on this thing where
if people ask you hey what are you doing
i'm a student yeah exactly i got my
cover yeah i got my cover story yeah
yours is similar right because yeah
totally
right yeah freshman in college exactly
so
how long did you have the like okay so
let's take that when did you
decide all right i'm gonna do this for
real this will be the job was it right
away or did you kind of play with it
first and then decide a year later or
two so it's really interesting so for me
i was a it's so funny you were at the
show last night and so you could tell
especially in the bay there's just this
level of connection i have in this city
new york certain cities where i'm like i
know you guys yeah we're all kumon kids
and they're like yeah that's okay we're
like we're like type a like uh we're
good we got to do that you know i i know
you like i know you i know what your
house smells like i know the way your
mom talks to you i know you i've seen
you at family parties right i know you
like i really know you and there's a
level of um
intimacy there with that material
the point of the story is is that
i was part of that camp where there was
a clear track
um relatively speaking in the community
i wasn't the brightest kid every
community has like the stanford kid i'm
always like i go up to like people in
dallas i'm like yeah you grew up in
dallas right who's the stanford which
one yeah which one you know who's
nikhil yeah i'm like yeah yeah so
assuming you're not in a kill what was
your path
right everybody has one somebody's like
run off man bruno went to mit i was like
he's the star
who's the star of your community there's
a kid right yeah yeah you're not gonna
name him it's fine so every kid he won
the spelling bee yeah
and you're like you're like okay
this person is the shining star of the
community what what's my path um and so
i was a speech at a debate kid i go to
college and the first open mic that i
did
a friend of mine funny enough um
who i knew in college was illegally
downloading a ton of stand-up comedy uh
i went to college during like the kazaa
yeah limewire limewire i think we're the
same age i'm 36 yeah i'm 33 i think yeah
so we're like we're that same era
and um you said 33 i think yeah
i haven't been thinking about my age in
a while yeah yeah i think i'm 30. i
think i am 33 yeah i mean 33-34 i think
i'm 33. yeah of 36. and um so i i went
to college during that era he downloads
a chris rock special never scared i
remember that special he's in the purple
suit and i remember being like oh this
is funny speech and debate
this is connected to the dots yeah this
is forensics but funny right oh i i see
the matrix and then i come to find out
oh like a lot of the comics that i
really loved
there were certain comics that really
thought critically like that greg
giraldo rest in peace one of the
all-time greats he was a former attorney
right and he became a comic dimitri
martin who was really big at the time in
the early 2000's early odds he also was
an attorney worked at the white house
for a while and then like got into
comedy and he had a big run in comedy
anyways all these people that i like
carlin
they were these critical thinkers that
kind of were doing speech and debate
presenting an argument or a take and it
just was a light bulb moment
and i had this thing inside of me
i'm like oh this is one of the first
things in my life where
i have an alacrity and speed at which i
do this that i never had at kumon or at
the sat or at the mcats or at the lsats
like
i can pick this up really fast
and
i don't know if you felt this i think a
lot of you know desi kids have this or
whatever kids in general
your parents will put you in soccer
or basketball or swimming and you're
like ah there's always that kid yeah
from just the first drill picks it up
fast
and so much of adult life is figuring
out what's my thing that i pick up fast
like that
and that was that was my mom
21 years old
uh when we started that we had this
business idea yeah and it was like we
didn't even know what the [__] we were
doing right it wasn't nobody does in the
beginning yeah and i remember thinking
oh man my parents probably not gonna be
cool with this if i because especially
this our idea was to create the chipotle
for sushi so it wasn't like even like a
business idea like oh
bioengineering blah blah blah like you
know some new microbial whatever yeah
why does it sound like you were high
when you said that the way you said
chipotle is like such a like i wish i
was that would be a better excuse we
just uh i just tried sushi for the first
time and all before that i was eating
subway in chipotle a lot i was like why
don't i just why isn't sushi served like
that the way i'm used to yeah there's as
simple as that yeah so
i was like all right i'm gonna did you
always have so this this moment this
problem-solving thing yo why don't they
do this like this have you always that
was the start of it that's what i'm
saying i didn't always have it yeah i
started to realize that when i write
i've seen interviews with naval and the
vols like i was always like why doesn't
that pizza place do this yeah i wasn't
like that and i i say this because i
remember i used to watch those guys like
naval he's like a hero to me right he's
like a mentor in many ways yeah and when
i hear him and you know you hear these
people talk about how they they just had
it from day one or you know early age
yeah it makes you think if you don't
have that your thing which most people
don't by then it's like i guess i'm just
not that type i guess i'm just not cut
out that way i guess they're different
than me yeah and so i'm always very like
a friend about it which is like nah
there was no signs of anything i didn't
know what the heck i wanted to do i
didn't know what i was good at until i
did and that just light bulb comes on
when it came on yeah and i remember
going to my de i remember we started
working on it and like you said i had
this alacrity of i was good at pitching
it was a pitch contest that we were
working on first yeah business plan
pitch
and were you a great student were you
like mediocre and that's why i called my
dad i said you know hey um
you know i'm thinking about doing this
thing i was kind of expecting the indian
parent thing which is like no stay
focused med school remember the whole
thing you just worked on for four years
why i paid for this expensive ass
college yeah like do that thing yeah
and he was like he was like i think you
should run with this like oh you think
it's a good idea because no i think it's
a terrible idea i think food business is
awful i think uh restaurants are
terrible idea uh i don't understand what
you mean you know but you don't know
anything about sushi so i think it's a
terrible idea in like 10 different ways
yeah he's like but what time did you
wake up this morning i was like i don't
know like 8 30. he's like and what'd you
do right away i'll say i started working
on he goes that's why i know you should
do this because the light obviously yeah
he was like that's dope we've been
trying to get you to like study and like
just care about it yeah care and like
wake up with your own
light bulb on and be able to go do that
thing what is your what does your dad do
let me ask you he's uh he kind of had a
career where he was in like he was an
engineer research like worked at a
company worked at a big oil company and
then he he realized like it was like 30
something he looked around he saw in his
office he's like my office is the same
office i've been for 10 years yeah i got
all these patents on the wall he said
like these are just like certificates
they give me to like pat me on the head
and keep me you know just to keep me
doing my thing sitting here like a
scientist like doing my thing he's like
the guy i hand the pat the idea to he
gets promoted he gets to go to london
and he gets to like yeah he takes my
idea makes it sound like it's his idea
yeah he's like maybe i should do the
business guy thing because it's like
those guys just take my ideas and like
run with it yeah so then he switched
into the business side and so that's why
he kind of you know most parents have
this where like the thing they regret
they kind of push their kids like no do
it you know like so for my dad those two
things was like social yeah he's like i
didn't i didn't didn't i didn't know
anything about socializing till it was
almost too late so like go to that party
he would drop me off at a party
you know he would be like you need to go
and i'd be like uh i'm scared i was just
socially scared i said high schooler
right i didn't know what the heck was
going on and did they let you have
girlfriends and stuff yeah they were
cool about it they were like whatever
awesome yeah so they were pushing me to
again fill the gaps that they didn't
have yeah and one of your mom was cool
my mom was my mom because
are you the oldest sibling
yeah so the oldest paves the way so my
sister had already done it yeah
and so my mom was like she had to talk
she went through vietnam with them yeah
she was she was like all right look your
sister didn't tell us anything and did
everything anyways yeah everything we
told her not to do she did and then she
didn't tell us which made it worse and
we found out later as we do and it's
like bad by the way i know the listeners
sometimes get mad at this they're just
like get to talking about bitcoin the
reason why this is no the reason why
this is important to me
is like
understanding someone's drive shaft is
so imperative to
um
why they are where they are
yeah you're looking under the surface
yeah like sometimes people are like ah
that's stupid but i'm like no cause
all of your
i'll just speak on my like my
field which is not big it's relatively
narrow if you take 100 comics
and you're all in the green room
you'll quickly see the ones that are
talking [__] you'll see the ones that
don't like to write you'll see the ones
that right use sometimes comedy in the
comedy club as a crutch to give them a
place to go to just socialize the ones
that love it the ones that are
sociopathic sycophants all of those
things but if you start to
find out more about them which is why
you know sometimes you come up in a
comedy scene i came up here in san
francisco in the bay you quickly find
out oh
this person's running from something
right this person do you know what i
mean
and that informs
the next 15 dominoes right of their
career in their life when you did that
because comedy i think is kind of known
for that like yeah comedy's like this um
torturous field where it's like you know
nobody makes it then even if you do make
it it's like
continue you have to come up with new
material reinvent it every year or every
two years yes it's just this brutal
field yeah and then even the the better
you are at it's you're a truth teller
yes right and often these truths are
kind of ugly or they're kind of painful
about yourself or about society about
whatever yeah so there's this like
darkness that's with like a lot of great
comedians sure uh it lives with them
yeah you seem like a well-adjusted you
know good looking guy
you saw the show last night did did i
come off as unhinged or no you came out
you came off like you came off like i'll
tell you exactly it came off
to me and i don't mean this ah this
might sound no no no no no no be
straight compliment yeah
you seem to me like somebody who isn't
the naturalist
naturally isn't the funniest guy like
some comedians you just see it you're
like dude
they could just be doing this at their
dinner dinner table yeah and they're
just probably slaying whatever room
they're in they just happen to be in a
big auditorium yeah yeah yours i could
tell and my sister even said that she
goes he works on his craft like you i
could see that the stories you were
telling the beats
the like the punchlines it just felt
like
everything was put together it was
thought through the lighting the sound
the like position where your body
language on the on the stage it seemed
like you had worked this set not like
this guy's just funny he had two drinks
he gets up here and he starts
spitballing yeah which is like you know
the vibe that some comedians give yeah
totally and so to me that was what i got
was like you're it's like it's ironic
it's like this is kind of like the
indian kid who like
does like hard work and practice and
he's like really good at the thing that
he set his mind to yeah that's the vibe
i got is that accurate or is that like
mine yeah no projection of [__] i think
i think that is definitely accurate like
i i really do care like i love it i love
this thing okay do the thing do you
agree with my first thing which is
amongst a hundred comedians that are
like at the same time yeah
are you the naturally are you the
average above average below average what
would you say yeah so what you're
talking about is just like natural um
there's people that look funny talk
funny say things in a funny way so
their voice sounds funny
they look funny
you're already in the top heap think
about those guys chris farley yes uh
another comic i love felipe esparza
felipe esparza just looks funny hannibal
burris has a has an amazing voice
chappelle has an amazing voice right do
you know what i mean yes exactly he just
like sounds funny he's brilliant he also
sounds really funny chris rock has a
great voice right right he sounds funny
um
yeah i look like a news anchor you know
what i mean like i look like i should be
doing like the five-day forecast or
whatever
um
but i also have like uh i have a genuine
love and i have something that i want to
say like
there's a message yeah i just want to
say something there's something inside
of me that i want to say
and um
yeah one of the things that i i
definitely
feel is like when i put together a show
like on tour i want to give you a show
right like i want it to be a show and
um for me
putting together mixing stand-up comedy
storytelling and theater
that to me was my elixir yeah it was my
elixir like
we were at the show i wanted i was
thinking about what do i ask him i was
like yeah i got a bunch of questions but
the one that i truly wanted to know
which i don't even know if there's a
good answer for this yeah but the
question i was like at the end
so you went up there for an hour and
like by the end it was like
you know in tetherball when one person
gets the momentum and it's just swinging
and the other the person the other
person is like flailing they're helpless
like the ball is just out of reach yeah
but the one person knows they're like
i'm about to you haven't won yet but the
momentum is so strong yeah from about
halfway through the show to the end of
the show that's i felt like it was
tetherball you were dominating and the
crowd was just in the palm of your hands
it was so good and at the end you know
mic drop crowd goes wild
what is that feeling like because most
human beings are never going to
experience that but it seems sitting
there i'm like that must feel [__]
amazing even though you've done this
many times oh it must feel [__]
amazing does that what does that feel
like you know what it feels like the end
of the set every artist and i think
every human being
um
whether it's intimate relationships
personal relationships
collaborating in business
family dynamics
and hopefully your career
everybody wants to feel seen
and there's this moment
in act two of the show where i basically
go man i want to give you guys all of me
yeah i want to close the gap between who
i am on instagram and who i am on
imessage right and when i look in
people's eyes i could tell everybody
that's in like the bay area work from
home crowd they're like [__] i can't be
me yeah and there's part of me how are
you laid down yeah when i lay down i'm
sharing all these secrets with you guys
yeah and i'm like there's this moment of
do you see me
i want to be seen right like when i'm
with bina when i'm with my spouse she's
like hey when we're disagreeing on
something it's like you don't see me
like you actually don't see me for who i
am right and the most um
enriching thing about that last moment
when i say good night
and i see people and their reaction i
feel seen
i'm like oh i think y'all you guys get
me right and to me laughter in that
exchange in that live experience is an
expression of love
you know what i mean because i can't
make you laugh i can't like force you to
laugh
much like love making it's an intimate
act right and that release of laughter
is like oh you get me right you feel me
it was the journey from the beginning of
the show so that's the end that's the
climax yeah that's that i feel loved and
seen yeah before the show yeah and again
we're sitting there and the openers went
on and we said okay he's about to come
on and my sister goes oh man like what
would you feel if you were about to go
on
and i said well you know he's uh i was
just thinking in my head i was like yeah
i know he's done this many times so now
he's figured out a system yeah
how to deal with that combination of
excitement and nerves gotcha uh what's
the what's the feeling like for you now
and what's the system you've developed
to get on stage and have that switch
flipped because when you came on within
two seconds it's like this guy's in a
state of mind he's in a state as we say
yeah of like he's here to perform he he
knows what he's here to do yeah there's
no like tiptoeing into it yeah so i was
wondering what do you do
the five ten minutes before or an hour
before i don't know what's your kind of
like warm-up routine yeah yeah i think
you're ready
the listeners want to know this i'm sure
i don't really i this is your personal
curiosity i want to know it and i've
my trainer has this great phrase he goes
who are my customers the people that
love what i do
because he's he's like people always ask
oh who your customers is some
demographic right some like some like
marketing intellectual answer he's like
yeah easiest way in the world is the
people who who who your customers are
the people who love what you do yeah so
just do what you do yeah you will
naturally attract the people who love
that yeah you'll repel the people who
aren't interested yeah you will never
have to guess what the heck people want
because you just do what you want so
that's the approach i take to the pod
yeah um
no i love it man i love i love talking
shop like this for me it's actually it's
a it's the three hours before
so
what i try to do before any show
i try to make sure that like i exercise
in some capacity
because
and i don't know if you feel this way
and maybe it's within our community it's
so funny to go back to what you're
talking about where you're like oh he
seems like a guy who works really hard
this is funny i was doing mark martin's
podcast and marin said the same thing
about me he's like yeah you seem like
really put together and he's like why
aren't you unraveling like the way other
comics are right and i'm like yeah
i'm just philosophically not from that
camp i'm not from the tortured artist
camp i'm more from the place of like i'm
creating from a place of passion and
love
and actually real talk it's about
emptying the tank
i just want to put it all out on the
court right you know and this court
happens to be the stage right um and i
want to do my best i want to be like
i put everything into picking out this
outfit i put everything into picking out
these jokes these tags the stage design
the lighting design like
this is it and i want to know when i go
to sleep here at night when i put my
head down on the pillow
i did everything i could right like
living a life without regret and only
you can answer that is the best
everybody's talking about chasing
happiness to me it's about chasing
satisfaction like that self-satisfaction
and you know what it is right you know
what it is right and you know when you
sold out you know you got a good result
but you kind of didn't do it the right
way yeah
that sticks with you
and some people just like
let that stick with them yeah other
people say all right even if i won i'm
not going to win on those terms again
yeah if i lost i can lose on these terms
and be good at night yep and and i'm
sure there's listeners to the pod that
spend their time retweeting the right
things and quote tweeting and dunking on
vc people
and you know they they say the right
things they'll regurgitate the right
opinions but they know when they put
their head down at night
hey you're supposed to train you jerked
off instead you were supposed to do this
you did but only you can answer that
right so you can signal all you want
for me what that stage represents is
like no
i'm putting myself in a high level of
accountability in front of 3 400 people
right i'm putting it all out here right
even and if you don't think i'm good if
you think i'm corny if you think i'm
whatever hey it is what it is but i
stood here right and i did it i did me
and on my terms and i did my best so
you're saying so you're saying three
hours before three hours before what i
do is i like to do the the uh some form
of exercise and i try to get out of
my workout workout or you're just trying
to break a sweat what are you what's the
yeah trying to do
on tour it's just about body maintenance
so i'll do
running
i'll do some pull-ups some core stuff
just stuff to get my body going right
and start breaking a sweat and what i
love about like right around minute 30
to 45
is i'll get out of my head and into my
body
and so much of life right now
getting out of your head
and it's funny i i called you randomly i
was appreciate i appreciate you picking
up the phone the other day we had a long
conversation we can get into that later
but so much of
i think what you do and what you put out
in the world and i call it like tech
twitter talk
it's all in your head intellectual it's
all just heady
anxiety inducing stuff
ethereum's up just solana's this it's
like it's all headshit right it's not a
body feeling thing right like grounding
yourself two feet on the ground i'm here
in this moment what do i do
and so much of performance
and to be great at it
the best chappelle the best performers
they're not in their head they're in
their body they're really there right
somebody screams somebody says something
somebody heckles they're in their body
when you watch steph curry play when i
watch devin booker play these guys are
so in their body right luca is the best
at this he's in his body he's in the
he's in flow right and so luke is like a
kid and kids do this well yeah kids do
this pretty naturally i love that the
older you get the more
you get which is you gotta yeah you
gotta fight that right and so
that's a great way to get out of my head
get into my body then i'll probably i
eat something
um i take a shower and then i put i put
on the outfit and for me it's like
being on stage uniform and putting on
that it feels like a uniform and like
for me it feels i wanted to feel like a
show
like from the watch to the jacket to the
pants i'm like
there's a level of confidence that you
have when you move into a room and
you're like
hey from
from my heels all the way up to my head
i'm wearing my armor right like i'm
coming correct right and you just you
carry yourself with a little bop you're
like no i feel better about myself
my [__] isn't slouching there's no
stains on my stuff you know what i mean
like the moment i saw you today you
walked in you're wearing your tech pants
i could tell you washed them a few times
but there's some stains on the back side
you know what i'm saying but that
feeling of like no man when i'm coming
in here i'm gonna be fresher than sean
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm just gonna
be fresh yeah
that already gives me a feeling of like
confidence i know what i'm doing you
know and and by the way the opener
marcela like marcella was just like
dressed to the nines you know it's it's
a feeling
then i get to the show um i finish
eating i'll meditate
so
meditation for 10 to 15 minutes allow me
to just again get out of my head
and drop into my body and something
simple just head space right like i'm
not getting too crazy about it um and
what i love about
headspace specifically is so much of it
is just basic breathing
establishing a level of intention
i'll meditate then i'll pray
and for me like prayer is really
important because it's got to be about
something bigger than just myself and my
corporal being i'm like what am i doing
this for
and just establishing an intention and
for me the intention is like love
let me give joy to people right and i
want the seed of everything that i'm
doing to come from that not be like not
be petty energy
angry energy
um i'm gonna prove you wrong energy like
i'm in the laughter business like i'm
here to make you feel joy right
um and that warm feeling so establishing
an attention there i get to the
i'll get to the venue about an hour
before
i have a double shot of espresso
um i'll let my bowels do what they do
you always get those jitters like you
gotta pee you gotta do what you gotta do
and then about like 30 to 45 minutes
before i like to be loose just with the
with the staff right let them know like
hey what's up how are you
door guy security guy openers right you
know what i mean another way to get out
of your head by the way yeah yeah
be with others be there yeah they're
serving others in a way yeah and then
um about a half an hour before
um i'll go to my green room i usually
write it down
i'll write down it'll just be on hotel
notepad paper hey what are a couple new
tags
that i'm working on tonight right just
move the ball forward a little bit
remind myself yo i'm gonna do this
um
[Music]
for example last night one of the things
i talk about in act one of the show is
fertility and a new joke that i did was
like you know what it's like being
infertile as a man
i felt like woody and toy story when his
arm got ripped off
that was a that was just one line and i
was like hey make sure you do the woody
toy story line right you know
and uh
every show i try to add a few of these
extra moments
and you add that up over the course of
like a year two years three years you
start to see what works and what doesn't
work and i'll i'll have a thousand three
thousand different variations of that
right
and then i get on stage and by the time
i get on stage there's just this feeling
of like
now it's just pure play whatever happens
happens right and um when i'm on stage
what i try to do is i try to remember
when
when i'm opening in front of my crowd
they're like really hot
and one of the things i try to remember
is don't yell don't scream
try to actually bring them to you
like set the tempo of the game right
don't get like too excited or too hot
like you can whip them up
but then like sit down at the stool
bring them to you
and like make the room feel like it's
coming to you
you know what i'm saying do you ever
watch a film of yourself basically yeah
i watch tape all the time yeah and so i
see bad habits it's kind of brutal huh
yeah
yeah but it's cool though actually like
those moments where you like
is very painful for your ego and
but there's a lot of growth in that the
only way to break through and get to
like the next part is is that part i've
done that even in the business world and
i'm going to keep bringing it back
because
that's where a lot of the audience lives
yeah the things you're talking about of
how to get ready for the for your
performance your day what you do
that's i mean
i athletes do this before they get on
the field you do the performers do this
before they get on the stage yeah i do
this before i get on my laptop it sounds
lame because i was like dorky but it's
like well i'm trying to be my be the
best version of myself yeah i'm trying
to set an intention before i go out here
i'm trying to get out of my head so i
can do my best yeah i do all the same
things and i just apply it into this
world and it doesn't matter if it's a
call with a supplier or it's a podcast
episode or whatever before you came here
yeah got it i got
through my routine yeah to make sure
that is your routine similar-ish very
similar obviously compressed not because
you know a longer day so i'll i'll try
i practiced it where i can do it in 10
minutes now i can get that state in 10
minutes that's my goal really
has three three components breath work
so this first three minutes of breath
yeah and so i can use breath to change
my
physiological state right away it'll be
push-ups and breath work so i'll just do
15-20 push-ups i'll do breath
next three minutes again how do you get
out of your head it's not about you
gratitude and think about others i have
this little exercise i do again sounds a
little bit cheesy but i'll say it out
loud people won't try this just try it
i just let uh i rotate through almost
like in my head so i'll visualize like
let's say my mom my sister whoever
people i love people in my life i just
visualize them laughing so i just
visualize them laughing which is them in
their joyful state yeah there's no like
i don't to think about why i laugh
nothing i just i've seen them laugh a
thousand times i just see them all laugh
in succession in my head yeah now i'm
not thinking about me and my problems
and my needs and my desires my i'm just
thinking about them yeah and i'm just
it's a good energy that i like yeah the
last time you do it you do establish an
intention i do establish it and then the
last bit is i remember why i'm here and
so the thing you were saying
you were saying i want to bring joy love
to the audience want to make them laugh
make them have a great time yeah same
thing i used to think what am i going to
say
whether it's a meeting a presentation a
podcast what am i going to say what
person going to show up what am i going
to say yeah
that used to paralyze me just like what
am i gonna say i want to get the right
words i wanna [__] up so then as soon as
i start talking there's a little editor
in my head being like that sounded dumb
oh yeah yeah
you walked up and you said that thing is
stupid
and then i'm in my head while i'm doing
the thing
and i wanted to just be clear
and okay how did i do that so then i
started stopping but i just i imagine
the end so i already imagine after the i
already imagine us
saying bye to each other at the end of
this yeah and if that happened that
means this all went well yeah and i
remember okay the people listen to this
what are they gonna be thinking they're
gonna be thinking blah blah blah they're
gonna be saying these things yeah dude
that that episode was amazing
dude i love hustling man
you have him on again he was so good
right so now i don't have to think about
what questions do i ask i'm already
remembering what i'm trying to deliver
and then it's i'm not gonna learn a new
skill in the next five minutes like
the performance is gonna be based on all
the hard work i've done over a decade
about whatever i'm doing yeah so i don't
try to like cram for the exam
i just try to put myself in the right
state of mind so i just performed the
way that the things i already know how
to do yes that's my routine for for you
know my how to start my day how do you
get over
you're part of this thing again i call
it like the business internet world yeah
which can be filled with
people that are sincere in their
intentions it's filled with grifters
it's filled with sometimes people that
are trying to do get rich quick schemes
you're part of this really it's actually
quite similar to hollywood and politics
in that way yeah because if you work in
show business you'll quickly see that
too yeah you know like [__] can run from
people that are like really about it
artist artists
nas kendrick lamar all the way to logan
paul and jake paul like that are just
about like the wwf circus show of it all
right
this world that you
run in and people are now talking about
money in business in a really
interesting way when people come out and
they comment about you and your
businesses and they quote tweet you and
they're dunking on you and that's a part
of now the social currency this is a
social currency that you're a part of oh
the more subscribers i get then i can do
me on these commercials and we can sell
the pod you're a business guy right
how do you deal with those
uh negative critiques does it bother you
does it
what's um
so the honest answer is yeah every
negative comment yes is like 10 times 10
yeah every positive comment you know and
so that is the initial reaction
but there's also a difference between
response and reaction so
the initial if i'm not in the right
state of mind that initial reaction
i'm going to clap back
or they're so dumb because of this and
this i'll go look at their profile you
only got 11 followers and you're saying
this [__] maybe yeah
maybe that's why you have 11 followers
because you think this way you know i'm
right you're wrong blah blah blah yeah
and i realized pretty quickly that
doesn't get me anywhere in fact it would
waste like almost like half a day or a
whole day of mine just checking the
mentions
for good and bad like this happened if i
go viral good you know i go check all
them i'm just addicted to refreshing
nothing you did an amazing bit about
this that was the most for me those most
relatable yeah
you played it up it was amazing yeah
people aren't gonna know this go see the
show you'll see this part about the the
the
comments likes yeah social media cocaine
cloud back cocaine cloud exactly
um but with that comes the the kind of
the the negativity and that also is fun
it's this thing in its own way yeah
and so what are kind of like where did i
land with all that yeah uh okay so you
know
the good they think i'm like a genius
guru i'm not uh you know my wife will
remind me of that real quick and you
know the other people who think i'm an
idiot uh scammer or whatever or people
who think i'm an idiot who doesn't know
anything about anything yeah or i'm
wrong or whatever yeah or they'll point
out that i've stumbled and said this
said this the wrong way or whatever yeah
um okay where is my focus gonna go like
focus on why i'm so great or why i'm so
terrible really does nothing for me
right
so i said okay i do need a sounding
board so i'll say so so i get a reaction
from people good or bad i'll be like hmm
let me just get curious
why are people reacting this in this way
i'll take a minute to observe that yeah
then i'll go internal and i'll say
what's my what's my judgment because i
guess my rule that i created for myself
was that i want my own opinion of myself
to be higher than anybody else's opinion
of me you mean positive opinion any
anything if i think something sucks that
i did yeah i don't care what anybody
else says i think it is so i basically
want my opinion of myself to be the
trump card
and so that works uh for self-respect
like yeah i stopped seeking the respect
of others because i'm like well if i
don't have the main respect for my
respect then
what is all this other stuff worth but
then how did you get that wisdom because
that's because we are social creatures
my trainer so my my trainer's kind of my
bro my train of running for my first
trip he's also like a kind of like a
he's like me he's like dude it's all in
the mind this is a solar player solo
player game yeah and we gotta train this
just as much as we train the rest yeah
so he he said something at the very
beginning he's like why do you want to
work out and i was like oh i just want
to get fib i've got real fat doing my
last company i just want to lose weight
okay he wanted like you wanted to know
the drive shaft what's driving you to do
this yeah what's making you think that
what's making you think you're fat
what's making you
why'd you call me today why today why
didn't you call me six months ago what
changed yeah and eventually got down to
i had this experience i went with my two
best friends who are business kind of
like mentors bit older than me
all the things i do they've done a
little bit more yeah and we all went on
a spartan race together and
i thought i'm a little out of shape oh
we're all out of shape it's no big deal
yeah we went on the spartan race and i
was way behind and i was just huffing
and puffing and i was dying on this
thing and they were like trying to help
me and every time they helped me i just
felt like a [__] i was like oh man wow
like this is embarrassing i'd rather
they just ran and finish the race right
and left me to like you know die on my
own on this map
the worst thing you could do is like
push for me from behind because i'm like
it's like don't give me the pep talk no
anything but yeah yeah so i told him i
said
i was pretty embarrassed i had this the
situation i said i just want to like
have the respect of the people i respect
i thought that sounded like a good thing
to say yeah and he goes he goes like i
respect he goes respect's one of those
things um because you want to give it
not seek it he goes so he does two
things he goes uh we're not gonna do
this we're not gonna start this program
from a place where you're trying to get
the respect to others he goes
whenever you feel you lack it's time to
give
so like let's not worry about who you're
who what respect you're trying to get
from others and who you're trying to
prove to yourself to and all that
let's become a giver of respect to
yourself and to others so and so we
started flipping the script and this
became one of my philosophies which is
whatever you feel like you lack in the
moment that's a signal it's time to give
that exact thing
and when you give it you realize i got
it i have it in abundance it's kind of
like a
circular way of thinking about it yeah
but that was the the thought process for
me at least uh on this on this topic i
guess that's cool yeah
that's really interesting man i don't
know you know i
i know i called you
about uh
one of your tweets that went viral again
and it was about
how
it was specifically about the metaverse
and how the digital world will matter
more than the physical world
and i think the reason why it so deeply
philosophically rubbed me the wrong way
was because the pseudonymous digital
world has commodified cowardice
in such a way that the real world and
the game checks you and what do i mean
by that
you know i grew up i was a you know desi
kid who'd play at 24 hour fitness right
you play ball at 24 fitness first to 12
straight up or win by two but if you
lose get the [__] off the court right i
remember there'd be these guys
these guys that were nice
it'd be 11 11 straight up this dude
would step back hit it and as he's about
to hit it he'd go get the [__] off the
court right and you would respect it
because he stood there and he's like i
beat you 12 to 11. it's over this is
there's no argument yeah this is our
objective this is objective reality next
yeah and you got to sit there and you
got to run it back you got to wait
another one game or two games or three
games and then run it back
but for the first time in history
there are people that stand on stage
that stand on the stage of business or
life or comedy or art and they use their
actual government name
and then pseudonymous trolls
who don't use their government name can
launch digital drone strikes right
attacking you your character your family
that can then potentially impose
economic sanctions upon your future yep
and they do it pseudonymously
yeah philosophically i don't rock with
that say that [__] with your chest right
get on the court with me at 24 hour
fitness let's cook like let's play each
other
that's what it's that feeling that
fundamentally bothers me this is a
dishonorable craft right it's not
honorable
it's not a fair fight
the way i look how do you think i should
unpack that that's the problem i was
like why does this bother me yeah well
that's the first good that that's the
right question yeah which is not why are
they doing this why is this election why
does this bother me right the curiosity
is what will set you free because you
got to say do i enjoy yeah focusing on
this do i enjoy this like trap this like
uncontrollable yeah you're not gonna
stop it yeah we all agree on that you're
not gonna turn them all off right so
that's not gonna happen the world now
this is the world and i'm also thinking
about my children too because i'm trying
to prepare i got a three-year-old and
one year old how do i prepare them for
this new world order right and in a
weird way let's i'll keep i'll keep
riffing this out with you let's figure
this out
in a weird way there's times where i'm
like yo i wish you punched me in the
face actually
i would prefer that how many fights have
you gotten in your life i've gotten into
three okay i've gotten three i've lost
all of them yes
one time some kid was trying to steal my
shoes i didn't let him and then he just
beat the [__] out of me but i'm proud
like yeah i kept my shoes he wanted my
jordan 13's but i kept him um
but i but i remember i remember being
like i like the
the irl nature of this
there is some level of virtue even in
this fight right that it that it ends
and it ends today we've resolved this
here right which is why you see when
people fight
it's gone the beef is usually gone out
it's gone as long as the fight was on
fair terms yeah both people are like
sort of mutual respect by the end yeah
it's over yeah it's over and settled um
that doesn't happen yeah this is the
first time where
we don't really have that
and um
the reason why i'm saying say say it
with your government name
if someone says sean is corny or hussein
is corny
anytime any
comedian or contemporary says that i go
cool put up your hour against my hour oh
i'm corny i'll do 10 you do 10. right
let's see what it is let's play the 12.
right let's play the 12.
like i love the dance of it straight up
or win by two well it's a merit-based
thing yeah but but when baldwin is a
merit-based thing again you said you can
get up on stage yeah even no matter what
your name is
you can't make them laugh yeah you can't
just force them to laugh yeah it is
marriage you must earn that laugh it's
why my favorite thing right now in pop
culture is the verses right i don't know
if you saw dipset versus the locks but
you could see jadakiss
go up against right dip set and i
thought dipset was going to win but
jadakiss was so nice
he just buried them and it was it was
let's play to 12. right you play your
records i'll play my records and i and
there's something so honorable in that
in this new digital world order is so
not honorable right because there's no
reconciliation at the end either
so i quote tweet you
and by the way [__] posting is now
incentivized so actually being a
negative nancy and being an absolutist
in your position
is now commodified and incentivized so
that you can't even recognize yo you won
i lost good game and there's no shake on
it well it even gets worse because what
you say online what you display online
the photo you take online is so easily
faked so it's not even like 20 it's it's
like if instead of going and playing
that 24 hour fitness we each submitted a
mixtape yeah and so here's my mixtape
versus mixtape like well how much
editing really is going into your
lifestyle your opinion your persona yeah
your face all of it is filtered yeah
it's edited is curated leaving out the
bad [__] and the more real you are so
the way i look at this and by the way
i'm not by the way i'm not [__] on
digital skills so if two people are
competing against each other in video
games i still like that like there's npa
2k tournaments but it's are you better
at 2k than me right so i think about
like the way in which i want to live my
life and i want my kids to live
honorable lives too hey compete and
there's no there's no there's nothing
wrong with losing but like be a good
competitor be an honorable competitor
say good game right but when i'm using
my government name and ball drape 79 is
risking nothing
i'm like this is whack this game is
whack
and in baldrave even you can't deny that
but
i don't know if the people on the other
side recognize that well go ahead i mean
i just love your analysis on this so i
guess the way i look at it is
with the the pendulum has swung so uh
before and you know sort of like in the
past
when everybody was online uh everybody
was in real life real name merit based
you had still had people's opinions in
their heads they just couldn't broadcast
it um people if somebody if somebody
thought you were corny before they were
thinking that they weren't saying it
they couldn't get amplified from each
other or they would say it and you're
like okay cool so you think i'm corny
it took a buy-in they had to annie up
yeah they were gonna let's square off in
the lunchroom so you think i'm corny now
i can make fun of your shoes i can make
fun of your hat i can make fun of you
know what i mean who you're dating i can
make fun of your mother's
the barrier to enter is so low now right
fake name fake handle whatever you can
just go on there say whatever you want
you know what we're analyzing right now
this is kevin durant syndrome kevin
durant is one of the greatest basketball
players on planet earth and there are
people on the internet that get kevin
durant and his feelings riled up yeah
and then he says he doesn't care but
yeah
so this actually but because to me i was
like yo if and i talk about it in the
show i'm like yo these memes hurt my
feelings i'm a person right but i'm like
yo if kd is getting in his feelings
seven foot two wingspan can cross people
over built like build like a
velociraptor but can move like a point
guard and like yeah then just like shoot
and sledgehammer on you like
and he's getting in his feelings about
these like layman's at home
we're in a
big fundamental shift in society and
culture in a way that it never was like
that before
yeah so i i think basically
the reason you get the rewards you get
are because of all these things as well
so
by you going out there under your real
name the real face with authenticity
telling your real life stories which is
what you do right you're talking about
fertility issues you're talking about
stuff like that yeah you're getting like
the score the meter is just running up
why because it's in such scarcity today
we don't get that from most people in
most situations so when somebody does it
you're running up the score real quick
right you get the benefits of being the
counter to all high level of accounting
you're running counter to it you're
putting it on the line so you're getting
all of the benefits and you're getting
the scale of those benefits before
without technology right you'd be doing
local shows and
i saw this guy in north carolina he was
amazing the guy you know in texas like
who i don't i'm not a fan of that person
i've never seen them yeah you do the
netflix show you do twitter you do stuff
like that you're reaching everybody
everywhere all at once yeah and so
you're getting the benefits of that
leverage yeah and so you're running up
the score because that is what society
lacks today this this real like honor
code yeah of like look i'm gonna go try
to earn it under my real name and put
myself out there i'll let you judge me
and if i'm good i'm good if i lose i
lose yeah and i'm willing to play at
those stakes because you're willing to
play you're getting all this benefit and
people who are not willing to play
they're not going to get any of the
benefit they're going to get so they get
this proportional like
you know small bit of success if they
just like kind of [__] on you yeah they
get a little immediate dopamine hit but
ultimately they sort of don't ever
really their score never really goes up
so you're talking about the capital
markets it's the efficiency they will
reward they will get durant or whatever
yeah or you're getting rewarded for
being authentic and being accountable
and you're getting and with that power
comes the trade-off which is
would you like this giant prize yeah and
here's the here's what the hair on the
deal yeah here's the cost of that big
reward yeah where you blew up in like i
don't know five years or something like
that yeah the last five years you had
this like media meteor rise yeah awesome
it's because
you had the right answer when society
was going one way you were a awesome
counterpoint yeah you're willing to say
what you was on your mind willing to say
what was right and you used technology
to go viral as hell because you had
something good it went viral and spread
like crazy
so you're going to have to pay this this
tax this vig along the way and you got
to recognize there are two sides of the
same coin and so that's where it's like
the the
the 24-hour fitness scale where it was
everybody was being accountable yeah
cool
but it was only operating at this like
small scale
it's not it's not scaled up yeah you're
getting the benefits of this thing right
and with that comes certain trade-offs
and that's i think that's just like the
way i look at it and i think that that's
a good framing society's going that
direction and so you're already on the
right side of history here where
you're willing to play a different game
and because of that you're going to win
a very different process
and you're seeing that your career
basically is an example of that so just
so the listeners know i called you on
the phone when that thread went viral
and i said hey sean like and i'm so glad
you picked up very few people pick up
these days like real talk pick up the
phone and i go hey man like this
actually irks me here and you know i'm
such like a
i'm an artist man so i operate from a
feeling thing and then i start
questioning why do i feel this way and i
was like i'm an irl guy but when you're
telling me everything is going to be on
the metaverse i don't want to be a
pseudonymous drone right i don't want to
i don't want to
throw drone strikes at people that i
can't see
i want to talk about what's real and if
you watch the show like i'm talking
about what's real about me and bina my
kids right what i went through going at
dictators and and governments and it's
real this is real life i talk about
lawsuits and this just crazy [__] but
i'm like hey it's real it's my
experience right i'm being sincere and
authentic in that experience and i got
the receipts
and
i don't want to live in a world where
i'm a reddit commentator and you're a
reddit commentator and let's just like
argue at infinim that's a zero value add
to society to me right
but well i guess i guess what you're
saying is right you're like well the
more you double down on that so see the
capital markets will perhaps
right now for that accountability right
so the comedian who gets up there and
just tells dick jokes is not going to
have the same emotional resonance as you
going up there and talking about
fertility issues and then you're dealing
with it and what that was like and the
attention that's loaded in that because
anybody i just had two kids anybody
who's been through anything with kids
and that whole process yeah the
uncertainty like we didn't even have any
issues but my wife was worried that we
might have issues they loaded the
relationship with totally i'm sure you
have friends that went through it let's
get started earlier because it might
happen you know like
it's a connection so you put yourself
the real you out there yeah you get the
reward right comedian who just makes the
dick joke i laugh i move on with my life
i don't feel like i'm going to back this
guy the way that i felt like by the end
of your show i was like i'm about what
this dude's about oh wow right because
that's you that's what you did you drew
a line in the stand you said this is
what i'm about yeah you've told
you built your case yeah and at the end
of that how could you not be like right
right i'm on the island
if you don't
so it was a very different thing it
wasn't just laughing
it was like laughing but also
this is this person just put their balls
on the table and said this is what i'm
about yeah and you got to respect that
and then you got to react to that you
got to pick a side you're either about
that or you're not and that's okay you
can go either way yeah but he made it
very clear and then i'm like that guy's
going to build an army because he's
going to be there's a lot of people who
are going to hear that be like mm-hmm i
rock with them i rock with that yeah
whereas if you just did a bunch if you
just did a bunch of impressions of like
what indian auntie sound like i would
have laughed yeah and then i would have
been like next time you have something
i'm not lining up for it i'm not camping
out for it right because i don't i
didn't connect in that way right but you
did it so i think you get paid for for
doing that so you're saying just
be aware of that
be aware of that and and like recognize
what you're just remember what's already
working for you and why
why
that bothers you is because you're the
opposite of that yeah but there's also a
piece of it that could be you but you've
intentionally driven the other way so
when you see it you're like i built my
brand being the opposite of that so yeah
it's like when apple sees a poorly
designed product steve jobs was
disgusted when he saw other products
that were not thought well thought
through he was annoyed with it in a way
no other ceo was right because he built
himself as
we care about the inside of the [__]
design of this inside the case what that
looks like these [__] don't
even care what the outside of it looks
like right you know so like it disgusted
him in a way that it disgusts you
somebody who has no accountability sort
of stands for nothing just trying to
dunk on people on the outside right so i
think that's that's that part of it
to go to the metaverse side of it
i think it's not as different as you
think so let's say the world does move
to where
with these online identities
and that that digital identity matters a
lot yeah you know uh you have a screen
name and you know my first screen was mr
goobapple you know so like whatever
that's that's what's
yeah let's say that let's say that stuck
with me right yeah
it's so funny you know you know my first
screening was hassan
i've always been this way yeah
it's always yes it was taken and then i
remember on aim hussain minaj went
online you remember the door you see
here the sound of the door open of
course right and then i blinked in my
face yeah and i messaged him and then
it's just immediately the door closed
[Laughter]
so i think that yeah whatever your
screen name is it'll be the same like
this name you have huston minaj that's
what was given to you it's your it's for
better words it's your stage name for
the world sure and you're building up
you're building up a reputation
yeah it doesn't matter if that name was
mr gubapple or it was husson it doesn't
really matter what the real name it's
wherever you're whatever you're going to
make accountable you're going to say hey
if you like me if you trust me put my
reputation on this name yeah and then if
i [__] up that name has like lost its
value yes well the better verse you
might be able to pick a second name but
like
it it's still gonna work the same way
yeah where people are still gonna have
to put up or shut up under some handle
it just doesn't matter if it matches
your social security number it's kind of
like my my take on that but i don't know
it's it's a wild world of how that's
going to turn out i think we're still
like
it's just we're still a ways away from
that where do you how do you get the
points of like the things that you do
that you're doing right now like the
fact that you take time to train and
think you're you are preparing your mind
as a physical corporal being with two
feet on planet earth
rather than being just like this guy
with like the headset
and you're just like in the matrix you
know what i mean and your body body's
literally just being used as heat to
[__] be a part of this yeah ready
player one world yeah you know what i
mean and i'm just like yeah i'm not
gonna say i'm above that like maybe when
that's here maybe i will like yo i
remember afraid my kids are gonna like
tackle me and they're just gonna put it
on my head and just be like just join us
yeah join us dad i'm like i don't want
to do this well it's like i don't know
if you remember before the phone
i remember thinking it was like bat [__]
crazy that people watch movies on this
tiny screen why would you do that that's
like i don't want to do that that's no
fun i want to love going to the theater
i love the feel of the newspaper yeah if
you had told me hey you're going to
check your phone like 170 times a day
yeah i would have been like why would i
do i'm not a hamster like i don't want
to live that rat lifestyle just
constantly checking for my email yeah
why would i need to do that i can just
check my email once a day or whatever
you know like yeah the things i do
normally today would have seemed
really abnormal and i could have i would
have been kind of disgusted by some of
the things yeah and then other things i
would have been like there's no way that
you know like how would i be able to do
that it's not plugged in where would the
internet come from like how do you now
so now you've embraced that but then how
do you eliminate noise from your life
like one of the things i'm genuinely
curious about is like trung your friend
trunk who's hilarious online
[__] hilarious right
uh
my question is i was like
how much just internet garbage is going
in that guy's head every day i want to
meet him where is he in like vancouver
or something like that he's in vancouver
i should have invited him to the show we
are just in vancouver but i'm like how
much just
fecal matter of garbage is going in your
head for him to be like this is the meme
right he has to sift through right
that's his job it's filtering through
yeah yeah she is one here's a good one
yeah just hold [__]
yeah
um and how does it affect your just your
like your body and mind so what i'm
asking you and i would love to ask trung
is like for you guys how do you
eliminate just like this is just sheer
garbage and if 80 of your day is just
sifting through that which is so much of
what internet discourses and again the
algorithm is incentivized that just
people yelling at each other not
solutions oriented thinking and
conversation and dialogue
how do you then
have like a high efficacy rate because i
feel like we live in an era now where
you're busy but you're just you're doing
absolute horseshit
yeah this is where i've heard this great
quote uh from this guy
he's an entrepreneur i don't remember
his name but he told me something he
goes
he's talking about like i was like so
what are you doing outside of building
your startup like i was talking if i'm
gonna invest i first get to know like
what do you do when you're not coding
this thing yeah and he was like i said
oh i got some friends here's what we do
and i go he's like yeah we're making
music i was like so you're trying to
like make a band he's like no we just
like we make music together because it's
more fun than listening to music i go
what and he goes he goes yeah we make
videos i'm like you trying to be a
youtuber he's like no it's just better
than sitting there and watching youtube
he goes i have this rule which is
good friends consume together great fans
create together uh
he goes so you know you can look at all
your relationships and say what
percentage of the time are we just
consuming we go to a restaurant which is
consume [__] versus cooking something
together yeah when we go to the movies
we just consume something or binge watch
a show versus like try to make something
together make some art do a project
together build build of gingerbread yeah
it doesn't matter yeah what the thing is
yeah he goes like the great
relationships in my life i
i recognize they're great because we
create and the ones i want to be great i
create more than we consume right so
similarly whether it's even with work
i try to create i think most people are
consuming like 99 of the time i think
they're literally just
mouth open ingesting like whatever the
hell everybody else is you know the few
content creators are creating they're
taking it all in and then they're hoping
that their brain doesn't get like you
know turned into like peanut butter yeah
and
what i do is like i know it's very
addictive to just sit there and scroll
to feeds yeah i do it from time to time
but yeah i try to say all right i need
to be creating 80 of the content i'll
consume 20 percent yeah but of my time
that i'm thinking about content that
that's like that's like doing this i'm
not with my family i'm not in the gym
not whatever yeah i'm gonna be creating
yeah and so i can only consume to the
extent it helps me create how do you
build community
in the startup world is not hard because
entrepreneurs like comics probably where
we're all trying to do something really
hard build a business from scratch like
you know
works you know and uh
so like you know there's a misery loves
company type of thing where it's like
there's this
there's a rapport that's built amongst
people like we'll help each other out
we'll get along with each other because
we're all going through the same [__] so
my community became other people who
were startup founders when i was doing
that and now that i'm kind of more
creating content and you know building
an audience and a brand
it's people who are trying to do that
and trying to figure out like like we
have one friend pomp who yeah he's
amazing at content like he's great he's
building his brand he's like the bitcoin
guy he's the bitcoin guy yeah
but when i look at it i say wow there's
a lot of things i admire about what he
did but i also got to learn that like i
would never want to do what he's doing
he does this thing he does a daily
business show on youtube now every day
he wakes up five in the morning or
whatever and he's creating like a
three-hour live show yeah he's doing his
squawk box every day every day and i'm
like i get it that would work i would
never want to do that i never want to go
that path so i'm like yeah trying to
triangulate and learn from yeah he did
these other three things i thought were
[__] dope that i'm like oh that's a
great idea i should add that to my game
yeah it's just like any athlete
it's like anybody trying to get good at
anything you surround yourself with
people who are in the game trying to do
the same thing as you that's your peer
group and you commiserate and you share
strategies with each other and then you
have some people who already like have
done it they're kind of your mentors and
you go to them you know from time to
time and ask them for stuff i'm sure you
have the same thing totally i bet yeah i
asked the jedi yeah yeah there's a bunch
of jedi and then there's other padawan
that are part of my like contemporary
class that yeah all the time yeah and
how did you get good like when did you
go from suck to non-suck like because
everybody starts i believe that suck
that's like the pixar way i don't know
if you've heard this before pixar is a
philosophy which is all movies start at
suck our job is to like remove the suck
yeah so there's non-suck left
so i took that approach man the daily
show changed my life man seeing the way
jon stewart worked and especially that
institution
both daily show and snl love them hate
them they're part of their comedy
institutions
snl for 50 years now daily show 25
you know that
um
[Music]
are
these pedigree boot camps for
understanding the process about how to
think about comedy right and one of the
things that i realized is what john
taught me and trevor showed me
you know john really unlocked the code
but it's like it's all about your take
what is your take and being able to back
it up so it's not even being funny first
it's what is the take what am i trying
to say what is the take what am i
philosophically
artistically trying to say
and
um let's give an example you had in the
show last night you're like you met this
guy who's a private equity guy you're
like what the [__] is that yeah he's
like oh yeah we do like lbos you're like
yeah
as you get to the bottom of your like so
you use other people's money to buy
other people's companies and you ruin
the people's lives and then by firing
them and gutting them making them
profitable and then you flip it to
somebody else yeah you're like yeah i'm
not cool with that like yeah i think
that's a little bit of a [__] up way
to win is to like yeah this is kind of
like vulture just legal stealing yeah
yeah yeah yeah
that was never your money
yeah
also it's it's it's stealing well it's
legal oh just just because legal doesn't
mean it's ethical right you know bill
cosby got off legally right we all know
what it is and so like that is what the
joke i would start with that's my take
around leverage buyouts and vulture
funds right
then you start tagging it you can do
that bill cosby tag he got off legally
it's not right you know we all know it's
on ethical whatever what he did or
whatever the glove didn't fit o.j yeah
right
all right so you must go ahead okay
um
and then you start tagging and then the
funny just starts flowing from there and
then you go that's like this and then
you can just what are you doing you're
sitting in a room with like a few people
you're just spitballing riffing
bantering just like that yeah and then
eventually you got to put pen to paper
right and you got to start writing the
act one and you start to see when i
watch weekend update or when i see an
act one on the daily show or any of
those death segments i now see the
matrix i now see oh i know how to
construct a seven and a half minute
piece right last week tonight patriot
act i know how to do a 27 minute piece
on it right i know the beats and the
flow of that and what was really cool
was it just gave me that
um
that central kind of like
philosophy how do i do this
and so the first 10 11 12 years of my
career i was just trying to be funny
and what john in 2014 really helped me
unlock was like no no you need to have
like um
there needs to be an actual process and
purpose to what you do now i'm not
saying this as a virtue thing no just
you just need to be like even if you're
doing dick jokes or even if you're being
silly
there needs to be you need to understand
the game and how to heighten it
comedically right even stupid silly
jokes you know are
like that and so um
that was the unlock for me and then just
reps trying to get as good as possible
now my my next thing that i'm just
working on the most
is the jazz part of it
like yo just have fun that's always been
one of my weaknesses because i like i
told you like i'm a kumon kid you're
structured and so and so we're so built
around fear
and so there's these moments
that i try to have on stage i don't know
if you saw is like i'm just kind of
unhinged like
the first like three or four minutes of
the set when i'm just i'm literally just
riffing yeah when i was making fun of
the kids shorts there was a kid in the
front row of the show just short shorts
yeah
yeah the eyes were just like all up on
the chair and then like the seats in the
back and you know seeing people come in
late and then riffing off of that it's
pure jazz now jazz has structure but
there's also play right and then you can
go back
to it and like it's that organized chaos
that i'm trying to like start to tap
into
yeah and you're doing well now
you
i don't know how you were doing before
but i'll say let's say when was like the
when did things start getting real good
is about last four or five years yeah i
would say probably around like white
house correspondents dinner that was my
kind of big
breakthrough right national recognition
moment of like
you don't have to be a fan of the daily
show or just a fan of comedy like
i penetrated
you know
front page of the news feed type
fame and clout and credibility type
thing yeah and you uh so you start doing
well start making money doing this thing
which is amazing yeah so hard to do so
you did it uh yeah and
what do you do so let's
talk about the breakout how you broke
through but now that you're here you've
arrived you're doing really well now
business side of things yeah how are you
running the show so what are you just in
like dude i'm just [__] touring 24 7.
i don't even think about the money just
goes on an account i don't think about
it yet are you like investing what are
you what are you thinking about yeah and
so you know that's the real interesting
thing is now i'm starting to think more
about the business side of things not in
so much of the
i'm a venture capitalist i want a 100x i
want a thousand x
the way show business works i think like
any business really but show business
per specifically is extremely predatory
and it's built on this idea that
um we provide the labor and
they're kind of banking on you being
desperate dumb
and not owning your ip and
right content creation they kind of are
banking on that and they meaning like
the big studios the big streamers the
powers that be the agencies all those
sort of things
they're banking on you not knowing what
it is
and i think for the first time in
history we're starting to see
close groups of collaborators starting
to come together and build things
themselves right they can still run them
through the big pipes in the studio
system but they're also like no no we
independently operate we cook everything
we write everything completely so like
me and prashanth we started a company
and we write we produce we executive
produce people's projects but we do the
whole thing kit and caboodle right and
hypothetically sean would come to me and
go hey listen man i'm hosting this
15-minute event at this thing
and
um i want it to [__] rip i want it to
kill i go cool let's what's your take
what do you want to say blah blah blah
come sit down with me in pv let's break
down your act one right and we'll tag it
up
and do all that stuff
and that's a cool opportunity for us to
collaborate and for us to brown paper
bag amongst each other
and i love the ethos of that like hey
let's build together right you're an
artist and a creative i'm an artist and
a creative i think lawyers are important
i think agents are important they're
fine but they're necessary evils this
brown paper bag this honest relationship
that we have as artisans together is of
you know the paramount importance
and the more artists we can learn about
just the business side of things
i think it's going to be for the for the
better
the other the other part of it man is
i'm just i'm
so much of my life was just trying to
make it yeah now i don't even know what
to do with money i'm trying to
understand what is money what to do with
it right and what's your mindset now so
what if where have you arrived on that
to me money represents you know um
in capital represents two things
money will not solve all your problems
but money can take care of certain
certain problems so if there's ten
problems four of them say child care my
daughter's braces
uh you know being able to uber back and
forth to the airport i can take those
problems off the table right it will not
solve my marriage it will not make me a
loving father or an attentive father
those are problems i have to solve that
won't make me in shape it won't help my
mind but at least taking those pain
points off the table means a lot to me
but there's another data point as an
artist that money can help solve two
things
it gives me the opportunity to say no to
things you have [__] you money like uh
you should host this game show nah i'm
not gonna do that right
it also gives me the opportunity to
imprint my world view upon the world on
my terms right so this so the show you
saw i own it outright right i
i'm not just in the comedy business
i'm in the trucking business like i i
own and operate that 18-wheel truck
you're like mayweather those lights
those like the there's the holodeck that
i'm standing on that glows like i own it
like you know i don't know what i'm
gonna do with it after the special but
there's a sense of empowerment of yo i
want to say this in the world and i have
the capital to imprint my world view
upon the world right and that there's a
deeply empowering feeling in that
the next thing that
i'm trying to learn and the reason why
i want to be on podcasts and meet people
like you is
artists we need to learn more about how
money works so once you make it
and you want to buy a house and provide
for your family and you know hopefully
have child care in some capacity and
how do you not blow it on dumb [__] to
the point where it gets really sad man
there's a lot of artists and
entertainers you'll get hit up and
they'll be like hey so-and-so has cancer
we need to do a comedy benefit to pay
for their medical bills
i'm like this is sad man this guy was on
snl this guy was on blah blah blah this
guy was on a sitcom
and i'm like
yeah this has to stop right and
um my question to you would be and this
is the thing i'm trying to figure out is
if you were an artist and you all of a
sudden we make our money in lump sums
you all of a sudden were given two
million dollars a million dollars five
hundred thousand you just make these
lump sums what would you do with that
money
yeah that's the fundamental question
that i'm trying to figure out and answer
well the first thing is there's gonna be
a bunch of people telling you what to do
with your money and you gotta correct
them at all costs correct the people
that are swooping in with the next great
opportunity and trying to get you to buy
[__] you know kentucky fried chicken
franchises and [__] like that like yeah
you have to sort of say all right
how do i get a trusted person who is an
expert at this yeah that is actually
good at their job and how do we align
our incentives so that they're not able
to just pillage me uh like happens to a
bunch of athletes yeah um they're not
just my homeboy you know from from high
school or whatever yeah i trust them but
they're not video experts like yes find
that intersection of trust and expert
can i tell you where where it gets
really hard you know i'm fortunately
like again i grew up i'm kind of just
you know i'm a nerdy kid i was never i
don't roll with an entourage right you
know i pulled up in an uber he heard
like solo with my backpack so i don't
have all those pitfalls that other uh
artists and entertainers have where
they're a couple of jewels yeah jewelry
purchases a couple car purchases and a
divorce away from just like losing it
all yeah you know
i'm a pretty like level-headed you know
guy that being said
you know it's interesting
you you try to do your research and it's
it's crazy i'm 36 years old i'm starting
to read about um
[Music]
you know
financial literacy and stuff like that
and i'll read books i'll read jail
collins book
you know
and you know he's an advocate of vtsax
right just vanguard funds yeah but when
i go on the internet and i start looking
through your mentions and i go through
your page or sam's page
and nobody's trying to [__] with bts
like you old man
you're not on the solano team
how do i how do you figure discern truth
ontological truth reality and light
from just this banter just this just
never ending yeah up down nature of
noise so here's what i would do all
right so here's how i would break it
down i'd say what do i want so there's
some people who are saying i'm trying to
become ditty i'm trying to become kevin
hart i'm trying to do whatever i'm
trying to have this mega mega empire
billion dollar status some people who
say look i came from nothing and i got
this thing now i'm not i need a certain
level of security and safety that's what
makes me happy is knowing i can never go
down to zero knowing that i can never
[__] up and lose at all it is it is
safety for life for me and for my kids
what is that number yeah so you start to
play with these numbers you start saying
what does life cost and what do i want
what are my goals with this what's my
burn right now you first got to take
that lay of the landings i don't need
any strategy without an objective so any
strategy is meant to get you to some
objective and what most people do wrong
is they're just picking strategies
without really curating the objectives
yeah and why why why is that thing can i
stand and defend why i believe that this
is what i'm going for that this is my
strategy um like how do i get to the
point where i know what i want and i i
can defend what i want to myself not to
you know like i can articulate it yeah
actually why i've decided that and i
said no to these other plausible paths
that might be right for others but
they're not for me yeah so you set your
goal that way so that's the first my
most important my goal is two things and
i've identified them because i think
about these things for a long time you
know being on tour is really good
because you just start to planes are
great you just have a lot of time
shower in the air
and one of the things that i thought
about it was like it's two things it's
like to me being a father and a husband
means providing financial safety and
security for my kids you know i grew up
in a family i want to give away i want
to talk about this too much but money
was always a thing that people in my
family argued about and i never wanted
that to be a thing here and it's a tough
thing to do if you're an artist are you
kidding me that's why did you pick that
path but it was it's what's honest to me
but
to me what what money and business
represents is okay if i can earn enough
so that god forbid this goes to [__] but
i have enough run right one runway room
and this is gonna sound crazy but for 10
years
because i do deep work
like it took me two and a half three
years to write this show right it took
me a long time to put it together
and i hope the depth of that resonated
with you into the audience that's my
dream like yo do you do you feel how
what this meant to me and what this i
hope i hope you see me i hope you see it
i hope you feel it too
but in order to do that i have to have
runway room yes i have to have two years
to be able to hole up and write this
movie right this thing i have a couple
projects that are now lined up after we
shoot this netflix special but they've
required a ton of time right
time you need financial capital to cover
your burn yep to cover like i said you
know my daughter a baby girl she has
glasses now escalating burn yeah yeah
and now there's all these additional
things my mom her knees are going she
needs knee replacement surgery you know
i'm the eldest these are real things and
i i put it as like no i need that burn
for you know 10 years right but now we
live in a world where we're not even be
able to retire yeah so i have to start
thinking no
i got to be rocky i want to be mel
brooks i want to be doing this
you know hopefully dick gregory i'm
doing this until i die right i love that
dick gregory died with dates on the
books
he was gonna do rooster t feathers in
sunnyvale california
living legend man and i'm and i'm like
what an inspired life right so many
people are like well he wasn't the
biggest comedian i'm like bro you lost
the plot yeah exactly he's still playing
the game like what a beautiful thing in
his 80s right god god give please give
me life so i can continue to do that so
that's it's that burn what's that number
ten maybe ten years five years and i've
told my accountant this right
then the other thing is is what is the
financial capital that i need
to then continue to imprint my vision
upon the world
so the show that you saw
the burn to run it
man is almost 40 grand a week just in
labor cost trucking costs getting it to
venue to venue it's a lot right now do
that at scale i'm touring for six months
eight months nine months a year got to
take it over to europe to asia to
australia
all of those things it's like
i want to be able to count on creative
capital yeah only on myself i'm not
asking for a network
you know so funny like one of the things
that artists now complain about is like
the studio said this and i'm like hey
man we got to shift to now being like no
no we have that
now in order to do that
i got to be able to make money not at a
1x yes 2x 5x i have to start making
moves that can potentially 10x it
because it can then cover that burn so
those are my two missions yep how do i
continue to do king's gestures and take
care of my family i'm not trying to be a
billionaire it's just those two things
yeah so that that will give you a number
or set up a range yeah then you say all
right what are the strategies that give
me that get me to that you're not going
to know them yourself because you're
like well i spent 10 years getting
[__] amazing at comedy not
the money game right the money game is
its own game i'm going to respect that
the same way when i'm like dude i want
to do comedy i know
comedy means it's a game that i i know
what it was like to be an absolute
beginner in business i got my ass kicked
for eight years straight yeah it's
probably gonna feel very similar if i
ever wanted to like even just like have
the experience of going and doing a
five-minute comedy set i'm probably
gonna have to get my ass kicked for like
a year or two yeah to just be able to go
do that yeah so you gotta say all right
how do i find somebody that's gonna do
that and i need somebody who
uh i need them more than they need me
yeah that'd be a great thing to have
right because a lot of people who need
you they need you for the clout they
need you for the money they need you for
many things so you need to find somebody
who doesn't really need you they're
happy to help they're happy to offer
they get something of it it has to be a
mutual exchange yeah
but they're good already and so that's
why i like hanging out with people who
are good already so when i go to them
they're not trying to dig into oh yeah
here's the business here's what you
should do by the way can i get some
advisor shares can i get some equity
it's like well you don't they don't need
that because they they're already
playing the game at a higher level in
the money game so they don't need me for
money when it comes to that so i can
trust their advice from that sense
because yeah or you know they're not
looking for that
so then you get a bunch of strategies
all right here's my
my safety my safety playbook i want this
amount of money that's in something like
vanguard low-cost etfs that's expected
to grow seven percent i could chart that
out and say all right that's what that
looks like over 10 years
then i need my high risk high reward
part of the portfolio that's that's the
that's the thing and i've read those
books like jason calcanis has a book
where he's just like hey take a hundred
thousand dollars and turn it into 100
right let me ask you this is that real
that part i do not believe is real this
is what i don't very misguided and i
don't know
you know my whole thing is you know
and you can like it not like my comedy
whatever
but i'm trying to meet people where
they're at right i love people bro like
i never want to lose i call it the cost
of milk energy
if you ask my dad how much is milk my
dad will be like in manhattan at the
bodega or at costco over in new jersey
if we go over the bridge he'll tell you
the cost of milk i love that like
knowing how much gas is right knowing
how much it is to like lease or buy a
corolla that's why i drive an odyssey
right it's like man i want to [__] with
people i love people
so for me one of the biggest things that
i'm trying to do also is like if i can
learn
perhaps even through my comedy through
my gift i can help meet the people where
they're at i'm never going to run with
the a16z's right maybe who knows they
may they want me to they may want me to
like perform at their birthday party or
something you know the kids 12th
birthday they're just like oh they
really like haasen come do 10 minutes
but i'm talking about like
man
that i'm speaking to that it's funny i
had this joke that i did on patriot act
where i made fun of bitcoin the dudes
who like tell me to invest in bitcoin i
said i believe in bitcoin i just don't
believe in the people that tell me to
get bitcoin because it's all my homies
that told me to take out a subprime
mortgage in 2008. i'm like travis it's a
property yeah you want a media you
wanted me to take a second mortgage
and why are you just like all like
diamond hands now
you're diamond hands and me to death or
whatever and they're like you dumb
[__] look it's at 60k now yeah
and the comic in me is like bro keep it
a hundred keep it 100 with me use your
government look me in the eye
tell me honestly right the reality is
you have 10k in the bank
the cost of living in milpitas is too
high and you need that [__] to [__]
200x
and so you are betting everything on
this
and that's why my jokes are getting to
you now look me in the eye and use your
government name and tell me am i lying
so i think that am i being real check me
if i'm wrong check me sean
uh you're not wrong you're not wrong
what i would say is
but maybe i'm misguided maybe
there's a certain level of skepticism
you have that is absolutely needed yeah
and you're tr you have to get to the
root of yeah why are you saying this do
you know what you're talking about what
is in it for you if i do this you know
what you know
you don't want to be blind following the
blind yeah what i do one thing that
works for me that's like a hack a cheat
code when i was doing that sushi
restaurant thing i told you about we
were trying to find the perfect location
they said in restaurants location is
everything so we're like oh [__]
gotta be location experts we're scouting
we're doing all this real estate [__]
we're looking up and we just realized
hey chipotle puts like
you know billions of dollars in picking
the right location why don't we just go
right next to wherever chipotle is
and that's actually the strategy that's
uh that quiznos and a whole bunch of
other brands had used noodles and
company if you go look next to a
chipotle there'll be a noodles and
company there or there will be a subway
there they all just they're like well
they do all the research and they're an
attraction so like yeah we just go next
to them we can piggyback because they're
putting their skin in the game they're
not just telling us this is a good
location yeah they are putting down
their roots they're investing money
which means this is probably a good idea
yeah so i have a couple buddies who i'm
like
look
uh you've been successful in this game
what are you putting your money into now
and and what ratios are you putting them
out how much of your money are you
putting into these things and how do you
think about them i triangulate between
four people like that yeah i say okay
now i have a base understanding of like
where they are putting their skin in the
game they're not telling me to do it
because they get something out of it
they are themselves investing in this
and they're doing certain amount of
diligence that like they are in a space
that they understand and so you're able
to get there's an intelligent way to
copy and then follow yeah there's an
intelligent way to follow and then
there's an unintelligent way to follow
as well yeah the unintelligent way to
follow is i heard some [__] from some
guy who's got an incentive to sell me
this thing yeah and i don't really
understand why he's telling me to do
this and yeah i can't really ask him i
don't know what percentage of his
portfolio is in this you know so i can
shield some random cryptocurrency i'm
excited about yeah people oh you said
that was great yeah i put a half a
percent of my net worth into it because
i understood it in this way and i
thought had this risk reward you put 30
of your net worth into it i never told
you to do that yeah i never told you to
do anything but you interpreted x as y
yeah so there's an intelligent and an
intelligent way to do it but that's kind
of my approach of like how i would do
this i would say all right there's a
money game you got to learn i'm going to
learn along the way yeah i'm going to
speed up my learning curve by partnering
with people who already are playing this
game at a higher level than me that
don't need any they don't need the money
from me they're not getting a cut of me
yeah but they're happy to do it because
it's cool to know a comedian yeah you
know it's like
a social worker yeah yeah it's just it's
fun right and so like
there's that's how i would approach if i
was the other thing you said which is
important which is the artists have to
get leverage so like people were last
night when we were leaving the show i
was talking to my sister and i said it's
amazing this my dad was like i can't my
dad the whole time i told you i bought
the beer he's like i can't believe you
bought that beer at the show so
expensive that beer is a dollar at
costco i was like i know i understand
that i'm having an experience at the
show here i wanted to have a beer and
enjoy the show yeah uh that was worth 13
dollars to me i know the beer on the
couch which is crazy
and so he's like he's like i can't
believe so many people pay to come this
show how can they afford a show like
this and i said well people care about
like they're having fun like this their
budget i understand you don't allocate
your budget to that they do
and
he was like he's like he was like you
know this guy must be doing amazing
because he's he did eight shows or
whatever in bay area he's got a netflix
show
i'll say yeah he's doing i'm sure he's
doing great i said but also think about
like
i don't know what your netflix deal is
but i know that if i was offered a
netflix deal
i'd have to do it for zero essentially
right like netflix kind of knows that i
have to say yes to have a netflix show
yeah yeah so my bargaining power is
probably very low yeah so even though
it's a big deal and it might do well
yeah my negotiating power in that
situation my leverage is low right
versus this show that you own your
leverage is higher right yeah so it's
like
i say you know
just because somebody has certain things
you do for distribution and fame totally
dude monetization that was the comedy
central deal like you're on the daily
show you're on snl right to be on a
cultural institution exactly to get your
name built yeah they know like you can
they can pay you whatever yeah and so
how do you get the leverage back and so
that's where there's this idea by the
way that like for us who said that
somebody said this i'm stealing it but
why wouldn't comedians create like oh so
everybody's getting big bit big checks
from netflix and others to go do a
special now yeah
and okay here's you know i think
chappelle whatever something like 30
million bucks 20 million bucks i don't
know what the numbers are it's on that
rank very big upfront payday yeah yeah
they know they're making the money on
the back end otherwise they wouldn't
offer that kind of money yeah um
but also a key data point you need to
know is it's just like you cannot use
ronaldo's deal lebron's deal steph
curry's ultra max deal or chapelle's
ultramax deal because the delta between
who the capital marcus is playing number
one
man you gotta see
what buddy healed on the sacramento
kings is making right no because buddy's
solid but what is he but is he top 10 in
the league is he top 15 in the league
that's the real again i talk about the
costco milk thing that's the real
working class artist if you can't be
kevin hart if you can't be jeff bezos if
you can't beat chamath or whatever and
you can't ball out at a bill then what
do you what are the moves you make
exactly that's the way i'm trying to
operate my life hey assume you won't be
will smith right you won't be the
biggest movie star in the world and the
capital markets are going to pay you at
a thousand x
say they they pay you at 10x what moves
do you then do to have a healthy happy
artistic career for the rest of your
life that's my mission i want to
continue to make art that's honest for
the rest of my life yeah so i think well
i'll answer so but let's but
the idea real quick is the idea is
if the artist got together and created
the streaming technology now is actually
like pretty standardized off the shelf
you can you can have a white label
version of netflix yes in six months yes
um the thing is you need draws and so
like if
somehow and this is always the
coordination problem yeah if you could
somehow coordinate the key artist to say
hey we can own this [__] we can
actually create our own platform that's
a comedy streaming service yeah that
people pay for yeah and we're gonna
share the the dividends sort of like
meritocratically meaning if i come to
watch your show if i subscribe to the
service yeah because of hudson's show
yeah you're gonna get the bounty of my
my joining yeah and then if i also watch
you know three other artists yeah
they're gonna get some some cut of the
subscription it can be what what crypto
and other things are enabling is
a basically creator-owned platform yeah
somebody's gonna do this i don't know if
it's in comedy or if it's in some other
music or some music what's triller
triller's kind of like that right no
it's the same thing as a company and
then they they cut checks they get the
artist to come on board and then yeah
they pimp out the artist to go get
customers yeah and the artist feels like
they're getting a good deal because
they're cash rich but they're equity
poor yeah they're getting and you know
they might kind a deal with jake paul or
something because the triller has
nothing to lose so they're like yeah you
get two percent yeah you know they'll
cut that to one person yeah what i'm
talking about is if chappelle evan hart
if you could somehow coordinate the
forces that be yeah
to say let's create a platform let's
only put our art on this platform comedy
is one of those things where the fans
will pay to jump the fence to get the
thing yeah and they're willing to pay to
also support their their it's funny yeah
i have the answer to that um so that
would be a platform that would be value
it could eventually be valued you know
easily single digit billions of dollars
that would be creator-owned and then as
you cycle out and the next community
comes up they would just basically join
the syndicate yeah they'd be pumping
their fan base into it and they would be
getting their proportionate share based
on how much how much audience they're
bringing to the player so i'm presenting
so i love your analysis on this again i
don't know i'm trying to learn
but i'll just share the things that i've
learned from just being in the circle um
you know shout out to my man az az was
you know chappelle was doing all these
summer camps uh in in ohio and and
one of my comedian friends az i think
he's you've met with him
he was saying he asked dave he goes and
and i love
z's like he's always been a future
writer of remy right yeah and he's but
he's always been a futurist he's always
been 20 years ahead and i tell asia i go
hey z you got the al gore problem in
2000. it's like the internet everyone's
shut up yeah you look like an idiot in
20 years you want to be 20 years ahead
you want to be maybe like three three to
five years yeah yeah yeah yeah you wanna
be that guy with oculus and you're like
bro this sucks
that's always my thing i was like i
don't want to be the oculus dude yeah
you know what i mean you don't watch
jungle book on oculus i'm like he's
giving me a headache like cut this [__]
out
anyways he goes he goes up to dave he
goes dave man you come on bro you're the
goat you're number one you could just
put it up on dave chappelle.com and
everybody would pay you five or ten
bucks for 15 bucks 20 bucks maybe a
radiohead style a hundred dollars nipsy
hustle right proud to pay
and louie did that yeah dave's like this
he goes like this he goes
new fans
what about new fans
what that netflix billboard gives you
is it pumps that tile out in front of
you whether you like it or not
i don't know sampar yeah i slid in sam's
damn sam's i slid in your dms you didn't
hit me back
but
when he's with his wife and they open up
the doom
and they see my tile and they see my
like
my raccoon on adderall face
sam now has to reckon with that right
then sam he's sitting on the couch he
pulls out his phone and then he sees you
retweet my thing and he's like man this
indian dude what's up this guy let me
see this guy boom i've now picked up
sampar i know i'm a convert with you
your cousins are gonna talk about me
your your sister's gonna talk about me
whatever but i'm talking about new fans
you know what i mean
in the distribution they do to get new
fans on board
that's what this proud to pay movement
doesn't have right so everybody's told
me hey start an online shop i'm like
cool i'll do homecoming king low cal
kangas shirts cool
what about
your three other co-workers the dude in
that room i want them to know who i am
right so that's what you know louis put
out his last special sincerely louis ck
did you see it
no
why didn't you see it
because it was just a closed network
between him and his direct fans people
couldn't get outraged about it they
couldn't write about it which would then
get you to it would titillate you and
you'd be i'm gonna watch it right which
would that get you to watch it and he'd
pick you up as a new fan yeah it had
yeah exactly that's 100 it's closed it'd
have to be paired with a pretty
aggressive clip strategy right so like
one of the ways you grew
was not because i watched 160 minutes of
the correspondence like speech 45 minute
it was long speech right yeah 27 minutes
27 minutes it's because a couple of
those clips get on instagram they get
shared they're tick-tock they go viral
yeah and twitter instagram tick tock
that's where you'd have to basically
pair it with that that'd be the only way
that you could get the exposure is to
say there's great [__] we're going to
use youtube we're going to use tick tock
we can use whatever and we're actually
going to they're going to take the best
stuff yeah we're going to dangle it over
there we're going to let that be
shareable yeah it still may not work to
actually like simulate the new fan like
that's why that's the interest and the
coordination problem which is the
biggest people you want they're getting
overpaid by the networks yeah because
they're that's the strategy of the
network lock them in lock them in and
then every other artist has to follow uh
yeah at a almost below market rate
because this is where all the headliners
are you want to be where they are that's
what feels like a first class thing as
an artist yeah if i'm in the airport
people like what do you do you're a
comedian i go yeah yeah and then i go
yeah um how do i see you i go go
download the zone yeah and yeah and i'm
just like netflix i go netflix
because netflix has that the dumb factor
just like damn i man my kids watch coco
melon i watch netflix i watch blah blah
blah so the thing is amazon disney and
netflix right now they're running it and
i'm trying to think to me i'm trying to
have a barbell approach to it so if you
follow me on instagram i put out content
i put out videos tyler my videographer
we put out stuff but i'm trying to
barbell it and i'm trying to figure out
yeah how do we
start to monetize those things now the
most
the most
the
clearest sign of that that i've seen
which has a low cost of entry has been
podcasting
comedians podcasting and people like tom
segura people like joe rogan people like
andrew schultz those guys have been able
to
call me um call call your daddy you know
people in that podcast shepherd people
in that space have been able to build up
their own independent platforms
and have more leverage here's my issue
with it
i find it
very risky
to put up every single thought and idea
that i have in real time on the internet
i'm be candid with everybody listening i
have no hidden thing here i'm just be
transparent the reason why i'm honest i
love what you do i think what you do is
honest and sincere and i think artists
need to start to talk to people in your
space to be like you understand business
we understand art how can we work
together how does this all
how do these these two worlds now
merge right
without being part of a a
multinational conglomerate
and then have business affairs and
lawyers and all that stuff muck it up
that's the interesting new world that
i'm really excited about and um
that's what i'm trying to figure out
yeah i love it yeah
uh i don't know how much time you guys
have i got time i want to be respectful
the camera's still rolling are they
[Laughter]
perfect yeah uh let's finish up with a
couple of things you uh do you listen to
the bot i don't know if you actually
listen to this listen to the body yeah
amazing yeah um when you listen to it
you there's always the beautiful part
when a guest listens to the show because
most
most guests don't but they if they do
the best part is there's a moment on
podcasting when you're at home and
you're hearing people talk about stuff
and you're screaming either like you
don't get it yeah talk about this
instead or no i disagree and like they
normally never get the mic they just
have to sit there and sort of punch air
as
we just drone on about whatever the hell
we're talking about yeah yeah what are
those things that when you're listening
you're like i would say this or i want
to know about this or i want to talk
about this what are those things for you
as you know
you broke through the wall and you're
here yeah
for me
i'll tell you the moment that i loved
um
and by the way
this has been my ethos with comedy
writing and i learned this at the daily
show
you can only tear something down and
this also works with movie writing and
script writing
if you tear something down you got to
pitch an alt
don't just [__] on the idea pitch an alt
right and what's the alt joke what's the
alt take
otherwise sit down like sit on the
sideline you're not in the game
so if i'll tell you what i love
um
actually there's i don't have a
ton of criticism i've actually asked
those questions the one that i loved is
you guys had this run that you and
sam did there was two things that i
sincerely loved you guys had this thing
up if you had a million dollars what
would you do with it today
i loved that then there's another thing
that you did that was really cool it was
vulnerable and
again the reason why it resonated with
me is at a level of honesty and
transparency in it
you guys were candid about your asset
portfolio distributions right and sam
was like i'm a little bit more
conservative conservative and you're
like i'm more risky right and there's
two moments i love it was the thing what
i do with a million dollars and there's
a moment that you did where you're like
i want to move through the world in a
way what if i was worth 100 million
dollars
and i want to build my days around that
yeah but where did you get that from so
there's two things i love those are just
two things i love but i want to actually
just tag that with a question where did
you get that attitude that like that bde
that's so that's a that's a big dick
energy i had a thing uh i was talking to
the uh when i got when we got acquired
we went to twitch yeah and they brought
in this guy
who became uh like i initially reported
straight to the ceo and they brought in
this guy who became the the chief
product officer yeah and he was like
twitch is like this gamer young gen z
millennial type of product yes guy comes
in gray hair
uh doesn't play video games um you know
was like at google in 2003 or some [__]
like that yeah and he's
obviously smart and accomplished in the
tech world but seemed like so out of
touch with the product yeah so people
were like oh why don't we have this guy
like internally like rumblings in the
engineering ranks which sort of like
this guy doesn't get it uh like the
people already hate upper management in
general they always think out of touch
making bad bad decisions yeah so there
was this like skepticism is this guy
gonna get it and he would ask questions
in meetings that were like
oh like you don't like you do you know
what fortnite is like wait wait how are
you how do you have this job if you
don't know like you didn't know what
minecraft would you use discord for
exactly yeah but he was just he didn't
he was like i'm asking questions to
learn why would i ask
obviously if i'm asking the question i
don't know i think it's important to
know yeah you think i should know this
so i'm just going to learn it right here
like instantly he didn't care yeah
that's a bunch of questions
when i um he asked me he sat down with
me he was like let's do like a
one-on-one he's like all right it's
career career planning or whatever and
he's like so what do you want to do and
i basically when you when you sell your
company of this deal this vesting
structure so it's like you basically get
some cash up front and then it's like
after one year you're going to get your
next big check and after two years
you're gonna get an xbj if you make it
to year three you get the last bit i
didn't make it to your three i only got
two but wow at somewhere self-imposed or
you guys kind of yeah i was just like
this is enough i want to go do other
[__] yeah i'm surprised i even got to
two like one i knew i would do because
one locked in my family security so i
was like right i'm gonna suck this up
and i don't care how bad this sucks i'm
gonna get that year
i'm gonna lock in like family is good
yeah i'm gonna get the bag and so i was
there and he was like what is the number
if you don't mind me asking what is that
number in the bay area
i had always said six million i said six
million is where your money works for
you
every up till then you're working for
money your money works for you six
million why did why did i say why six
because i said all right you work
backwards so i said all right my burn
rate i think at the time i calculated it
i was like we're spending
like 20 000 a month okay was my like
monthly expenses and i said okay well i
don't know if it's going to go up or
down but i'm sorry i know it's not going
to go down it's probably only going to
go up right because it's very hard to
give things up once you have certain
services or certain lifestyle or certain
size house whatever you don't want to
plan to downsize i wanted to plan to
buffer in some growth i said okay so
that gets you to 240 000 a year okay so
let's say 200 how do i make it so that
just the interest on the money i own so
just the the gains on that money being
invested in in the market and i don't
need like a home run just like if i'm
making and yeah if i'm making seven
percent or let's call it four or five
percent is like four or five percent as
a target yeah so you just do the math
like i as the rule is i don't do public
math but you take 240 000 you divide it
by the five percent or whatever and that
gives you some numbers so i forgot what
the calculations were but i know the
number came out to about six million
okay let's say all right at 6 million
six million dollars invested would yield
an amount of money that will pay for our
lifestyle
rather than me going and working a job
or doing something that requires income
to pay for our lifestyle yeah so i came
up with this number
and some people were like that's too low
some people like your why is your
monthly expenses so high so look i i
like to live a certain way i'm going to
try to live that way like i'm not
telling you you need to spend this much
money yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna get
chipotle with avocado i like avocado
exactly the guac's extra i said give me
two servings that's why i wanted to be
able to not have any weight on that
right and so i was like all right well
that's the i'm trying to live that guac
life and so
so that became a num a target number
right and i said all right i want to hit
that number
and i said okay so you know i was trying
to secure that back so winding back to
this this question of how did i get this
this mindset
so i talked to the guy uh he takes me in
he says what are your careers so you got
the six though i got to the six god i
said all right well how do i uh post tax
right
you have to have it you have to have it
exactly yeah so i said all right well he
goes when you when you think about your
career what are you going to do and i
knew that the right answers say oh you
know i love to yeah i love it here at
twitch and i would love to stay here
forever and i could see myself being you
someday the reality was i couldn't i
didn't i was having fun because i made
it my way but i was like this is not
where i want to be forever yeah and i
was like i'm gonna be honest with this
guy i'm not gonna tell him and it's a
weird conversation you're basically
telling your boss i don't plan to be
here for very long which is in a way
saying right
don't invest in me
you know like don't promote me don't
give me opportunities give it to the
next guy because he cares it's kind of
like a weird thing but i decided i'm
gonna be honest so i told him he goes
alright what do you want to do
he's like then we don't need to talk
about this twitch [__] like tell me what
you want to do
i said well first i'm doing this so that
then i can go do this thing i want to do
because i don't believe all that i go
well you don't believe i want to do this
he goes no i don't believe that strategy
of life
i don't believe in this life plan of i'm
going to do all the stuff i don't want
to do so that then i could do all these
things i do want your mortgaging for a
future that may not happen exactly this
this is never going to come he's like
i've been around the block
people who have that plan
he's like very rarely do you ever do the
thing you want to do is it's much better
just do the thing you want to do start
that now don't spend five years doing
the thing you don't want to do because
it's a means to an end but then but then
what you're talking about is that if you
had approached that you would have never
perhaps gotten that six exactly so so he
had a different mindset so i said all
right well what does that look like and
so
so he goes why don't you just
like figure out what you want to do yeah
figure out what it required what what
amount of money what skills what you
would required and start accumulating
those so that's actually where the six
came in i said oh
i want to be able to wake up every day
and do a certain amount do a certain
thing which is basically wake up and
just work on whatever i was most
interested in right like i told you dude
i want to like i want to do comedy
sometimes i want to do it i want to do i
have these other things i'm like dude
why don't i make a song that like just
slaps like why was it a catchy ass song
yeah i want to produce i want to produce
a record yeah like i don't know anything
about it but like
wouldn't that be fun if i just made a
catchy ass song that kind of hit yeah
and like it's not i'm not trying to be
the best musician but like why not like
why why not write a book why not do all
these things like
that'd be a fun way to spend a career
that's kind of how i thought about it
yeah so i said all right well if i want
to be able to do that
um i gotta have this you need time yeah
i gotta have time that's deep let me
start comedy stand up dj
so that was kind of my mindset and so
along the way
um again i talked to my trainer and he
goes
if you want to have a certain thing
carry yourself like the guy who has that
thing
very simple really they fake it till you
make it thing not even fake it till you
make it
you believe you will feel a certain way
when you have it right that's why you
want let's say you want a hundred
million dollars
you want a billion dollars whatever your
number is five million one million
dollars
you believe you want that because you
think you're gonna feel a certain way
when you have it yeah
so let's skip all the middle [__] and
let's just
believe that we have let's let's believe
that we're going to have that let's
carry ourselves like that let's have
that feeling now don't punt the feeling
until the end when you're 60. okay and
maybe you've achieved your goal so what
he's basically saying is a level of
confidence right and confidence and
security and not playing scared exactly
yeah then the byproduct of that you know
the comedy take i had on this by the way
this is the way my brain works the
extremely wealthy and the homeless
actually operate the same way which is
what delusion which is what anything i
do isn't going to affect my life anyways
what are you going to do
the incredibly rich
that's funny and
people who are like the same mindset
yeah are are just like
hey what are you going to do to me what
can you take from me right they both
actually operate that same way
sometimes it's people that are in that
vast middle
that fear either direction
that are like oh i cannot [__] this up
yes yeah so so that's the the mindset is
basically don't wait
waiting is the enemy so when you're
waiting to feel good until you've
achieved certain things
anytime you hear the word wait run
that's not the right strategy and so
it's like anytime you're waiting to do
the thing you want to do don't wait
that's kind of became my mindset i just
realized got it you mean don't put it
off don't put it off right don't wait
till x in order to have y that you
really want gotcha so if i want this
feeling of security of of relaxation of
confidence whatever why am i waiting let
me tap into that now
so that became both uh had two benefits
there's the benefit which is you feel
better today
already already a win yeah instead of
feeling anxious and stressed and worried
you're already feeling good
but there's also a strategy to it which
is when you carry yourself like that
dude you carry yourself that way
you'd be surprised what kind of doors
are sort of open for you how people
treat you differently they yeah they
treat you with the assumption of where
you treat yourself why do you dress the
way you dress why do you carry yourself
the way you carry yourself
because people will treat you
differently life will give to you what
you're putting but i also feel it too
like i like being fitted i like wearing
like jordans yeah and it makes the
immediate feeling which is already good
yeah and then you get the actual like i
think this harvard guy called it the the
happiness happiness effect he basically
said most people wait till they achieve
a thing then they're going to feel happy
and then what happens is you achieve
that thing and you just move the goal
post
well this is not enough when i when i
really have it then i can do it you know
and so this keep moving the goal post
and everything he's like not only is
that obviously deferring the thing you
want which is bad
two he said there's studies that will
show that the person who goes into the
situation already feeling happy will
perform better on the test yeah we'll be
better in the professional setting we'll
have a higher likelihood of success yeah
we'll have more lucky breaks that was
one of the things they tested they
basically they gave you a test and like
you know the third line of the
instructions said like just go to the
end just type write the letter five in
and you're done yeah and the people who
went in with a stress mindset they were
just trying to solve all the problems
and they had to do the whole test the
people who went in relaxed and confident
they were more likely to observe that
little line so oh
another another break that goes my way
oh great you know like so i'm going to
skip to the end hand the test in i'm
done yeah and so that's called when i
when i started to learn about this sort
of like happiness effect this this idea
that if you bring the future feeling
you're chasing into the now not only do
you feel good now but you actually have
better results i was like that's
just the thing i want but it's also a
mindset shift where you're operating
different than sam sam's like i'm not
going to take those crazy opposite but
why
why is he the opposite yeah so what i'm
what i'm saying is sam may look
objectively or it's his subjective
experience at your
financial situation and be like you
can't afford that you can't afford to
start this like one million dollar fund
and just with randos off the internet
and just start betting things yeah why
are you doing that you could lose it
yeah
it served him well like i think the
other many ways to win what i'm trying
to get you guys to beef i'm trying to
get you
i'm joking i'm choosing i'm actually
curious play style like there's this
great conor mcgregor quote where he goes
look you're gonna feel some kind of way
anyways right like any moment you're
feeling some kind of way so he's just
like he's like why not feel unstoppable
why not feel i not feel super confident
yeah yeah
it's the same sort of thing which is
that there's many
ways to win
but you do get to choose
and sam's way to win and many successful
entrepreneurs the same way which is chip
on my shoulder my dad never loved me you
know uh i
people doubted me and that drives me and
that's why i'm successful and they'll
tell you this proudly
and i hear it i'm just like man you
sound like you've been suffering for a
long ass time you know you didn't have
to do all that right
yeah yeah i'm i'm glad it worked for you
but also like the toll was high on that
highway right you paid an expensive vig
which was every day you were focusing on
like yeah the grind grind set mindset
and you're you're focusing on proving
people wrong and how all right how it
you know the doubters and how you had to
like kill yourself to make this work
well i know people who did it the other
way so let's agree that let's agree that
both can happen yeah
let's let's also do a quick delineation
though when you said you're moving like
you're worth 100 mil
so
you're not i don't make
size bets like obviously there's
examples of gravity no but there's a way
to move to be like hey because i'm
serious because there's people that may
be listening that that are just like let
me get that
let me get that rolex daytona right let
me feel that way right
if it's 100 mil then that it's probably
a rolls-royce phantom it's probably a
you know what i mean a maserati a ducati
whatever that thing may be you're not
making those things are you uh yes and
no so in the things that matter like i
hired a personal chef okay
that's something that really the only
like the true wealthy typically do okay
i was like no i this matters to me i
want this is the number one want i have
i think it helps me and my family be
healthy we don't have to stress out
about making food all the time for our
daughter who's real picky and she keeps
throwing away we gotta remake dinner
right i said this will improve the
quality of my life i don't care if we
can afford it i'm gonna get it and i'm
gonna then i'm gonna afford it right
because i'm not like
i know i believe in my ability to go get
that money yeah so i will not limit
myself in the things that i really care
about yeah yeah it's a true belief it's
something that you really want for you
and your family truly wanted it yeah
you're not gonna wait again i was
waiting i said oh i identified all the
spots in my life i was waiting i said i
got rid of waiting that's the thing i
really want and i'm waiting for it no
more i'm going to do it now got it
but do i go and just spend outside of
like what means what i care about what i
have like
no i i don't and i don't because i also
don't want to be owned by those things
yeah every time you buy something you
know it now owns you as much as you own
it yeah because that bill
owns you in a way it owns a piece of
your time because you got to pay for it
i'm very selective about do i want this
enough or i'm willing to let it own me a
little bit and so then i don't need a
lot of those things and i also have this
like
this is
you're good at these questions man the
last thing i do is i want to be able to
have as much fun
whether i'm in a mansion having a feast
with celebrities is if i'm stuck in an
elevator by myself
which means
i don't want to have to i don't want to
have to have some nice [__] in order to
feel good
i don't want to have to have the
circumstances be going my way for me to
feel good yeah and so that's self
satisfaction that's you training i want
to train my brain yeah but that's you
doing what you're training your brain
you're meditating you're boxing whatever
that thing is so you feel a self sense
of self that's zero dollars it's not 100
that's not a hundred million dollars or
a hundred thousand dollars exactly
because the ultimate goal the ultimate
way to carry myself isn't that i had 100
million it's i just remind myself of
that if i ever start to feel like
because when i heard that what i what
resonated with me as an artist is play
big play are you playing scared cook
you're on the court cook
let it fly launch like be loose
do the impressions do characters that's
what my thing is like that's my goal
like i want to be loose i want to have
fun i want to be really get on the floor
use a basketball analogy i know you love
basketball yeah and researching for this
i saw your celebrity game got a nice
left hand yeah yeah yeah you go with
that yeah you're not lefty right no i'm
not done right but you were very nice
with it yeah um
the analogy is this
steph curry's not afraid to shoot his
shot yeah anywhere on the court once he
passes half court he's willing to let it
fly that doesn't mean every time he
steps across half court he just lets it
fly because he knows like
old the ultimate goal is to win yes
but he's not afraid to shoot his shot
he's not thinking about missing he's
thinking about making his confidence in
that mate yeah so i would say a very
similar thing on the business side which
is
i don't just spend like a drunken sailor
yeah or invest in the most wild [__]
possible all the time i'm not trying to
take every risk possible yeah i'm not
trying to shoot every quarter every shot
at half court
but i am confident if i pull but you're
not afraid to let it if i pull it or if
i'm feeling it yeah or if i believe i
can make the shot i'm going to pull yeah
even if i miss the last three even if
this is not what other people like this
feels right this feels right yeah i put
in the time and i have the confidence
itself and i'm not gonna second-guess it
yeah so that's where i'll make cool some
take some risks cool that feel right to
me in the moment but the overall
objective is to win it's not to take max
maximum risk possible yeah it's also not
to minimize risk it's to win and you got
to define what that win is for yourself
right my definition of the win for
myself is i want to have the lifestyle
where i'm at the manager with my best
friends we're at the table we're
feasting we're toasting that's what i
want yeah but i want to be able to have
as much fun if i'm alone stuck in an
elevator that is my ultimate win where
my mind has created that situation where
you can have all those things yeah but
i'm
i am impervious to the environment great
i will have just so that's my ultimate
win yeah i'll take enough risks along
the way to get to that you know as i go
that's great last question this is from
this is from me to you
people can be pissed by the way they're
like dude you had us you just talked
about your own [__] philosophy no you
know what people are going to be playing
no i'm going to say this right now for
the listeners and the watchers people
going to be like he interrupted sean too
much and why is he talking like this
about bitcoin like sean you know you're
not the star no no no i'm i'm coming
from curio i humble myself before all
you my first million people
so listen
i love this again this is what i love
most about irl experiences about being
on stage doing material in front of
people hearing the applause break
knowing that that joke is right because
i've corroborated it with the people
sometimes comics when a joke doesn't
work they'll be like [__] you i know
better and sometimes that works but
there's a lot of times where it's like
no no hear them listen to them see them
you want to be seen but you got to see
them
for you as an outsider you know we don't
know each other well this is our first
time actually meeting when you watch the
show and you see me
what would be
your advice for somebody like me that's
at this point in my career i'm at an
inflection point in my career i
represent a certain period of time
me my contemporaries me john mulaney ali
wong we're entering that new era that
the
bill burrs and the chappelles are those
are the elder statesmen of the art form
what is your what was your advice to
someone like me
looking at it from the outside because
you have such a great business mind yeah
i think what's what's worked for you is
going to keep working that's why i said
before i think you have zagged when
everybody zigged
i said everybody was going in one
direction which was which is
low accountability low risk yeah um
doing things under
you know worried about cancel cancel
culture and things like that i think you
have built a niche where you're not
afraid to call out the saudi prince
you're not afraid to call out the
president but you're calling out not
from a place of getting a reaction
you're calling out when you see a truth
you're putting your finger on it and
saying i don't care if this hurts i
don't care if this is a nerve i'm gonna
have my take on this i'm gonna stand by
my take regardless of what's happening
and that's when all those are the things
that have hit for you you talked about
that in the show yeah
so i think it's not that you have to
keep doing that the same exact thing you
have to keep in the mindset that got you
to do that in the first place you got to
self-assess
what got me to
to
observe those things what made me
curious where i observed those things
where i asked the question that got me
to that truth right what gave me the
guts to do this i felt like i had
nothing to lose trying to make a name
for myself now i got a name for myself
now every tweet i'm kind of worried how
are people going to react well now now
you're not playing the game the way you
did at that time yeah so i would say
first and foremost don't lose what got
you to the dance
second is the stuff you talked about
which is you're betting on yourself
which is your own production you're
owning your ip you're owning your
own as much of that pipeline as you can
from a business perspective because it's
what gets you leverage it gets you
capture the value you're creating you
create a bunch of value you got to
capture it you got to look at the supply
chain and say who's capturing all this
value who why is ticketmaster taking
this much of my feed
why is you know who
when i go put this special online what
do i really make out of this versus what
do they make how do i get their numbers
and how do i understand how to capture
value on the distribution side and not
just this side yeah i'll try to think
about those types of things and it seems
like you're building like for example my
mom saw you on the morning show i
watched the morning show too yeah oh
[__] he's getting into these mainstream
areas building the name building the
face there
and then you're gonna almost like that's
how you go get the new fans and you take
them back you build this funnel yeah at
the bottom of the funnel the people who
are going to know your life story
they're going to know what you stand for
all these things they know me just like
any product in silicon valley you create
a funnel
top of funnel is new fans new eyeballs
how are you going to go get them in this
strategy
middle of the funnel how are you going
to get them to get their first taste of
you their first real experience get them
to their first show
um get them to watch you know the first
20 minutes of something that's your best
work yeah how do i get that and how do i
get them bottom of the funnel which is
how do we get create maximum value like
oh a bunch of artists doing nfts what
does that look like for comedy right you
know let me play with these ideas i'm
not going to do all of them yeah but i'm
going to have brainstorming sessions
with guys like shawn and say yeah what
would i do with nft what could can
with nfts and i would start to think
about because that's bottom of the
funnel more like totalization yeah i
would think about that funnel i would
say all right i am a product and i'm
going to build my brand around that
product you know and it's a long you
know it's a long series of optimizations
totally but that's how i would think
about it yeah that's how i would view my
my craft which is like uh you know it's
easy to just get into the art world
which is like
you know i'm trying to i'm trying to
build myself and
you know tell jokes make people laugh
yes but like ultimately your product and
your experience from the mo like when i
showed up at the show yesterday there
was an hour long line yeah we got to
skip it likely because you hooked it up
yeah with with the nice like vip stuff
but
everybody their experience end to end
isn't just when you step on the stage
it's like from
before the show totally aligned yeah the
rest and i would say playlist when you
sit down
yeah we talked about the the interface
where you go buy the tickets how much
friction is there i will go look at that
whole funnel and i would say all right
i'm trying to grease this funnel i'm
trying to get them to these magic
moments with me
the first magic moment when i first made
you laugh on like clip on instagram
second magic moment your friend takes
you to a show you have a great time yeah
third magic moment is the follow-up of
that you know fourth is when you buy the
merch and actually the merch stands for
something totally you know whatever yeah
that's cool i've always um
i appreciate that because
the i cannot see itself sometimes we're
so in our especially as artists it's
what it requires to do deep meaningful
work but we remove ourselves from like
what you said the line four blocks down
the street from the masonic theater how
much you had to pay for parking then
what the show experience is like all
that stuff yeah right
yeah but i think you're doing great man
thanks man i don't think you need advice
for me to be honest with you i think
you're doing great no man hey this is my
this is my two cents for the space y'all
are working in i think um
uh
just continuing to
try to be a source of light amongst just
all this heat that's out there
it's really important man there's just a
lot of
garbage and trying to actually represent
ontological truth in reality for what it
is right
because you're playing with people's
money people are listening to my first
million for that thing i just want to
like let you know don't forget it's that
but it's that titillating feature yes
it's like when you hear that title
you're like but i want to it's but it's
just like i want to make a mistake
i came to laugh yeah i came to laugh you
making fun of our indian parents and the
goofy things that they do yeah
but why did i that's what that's what i
came for that's not what i what i loved
what i loved was
the stuff you're saying at the end the
stories about your daughter the stories
about the the the jerk parent at the at
the yeah library
or whatever those were where i was like
oh man i attached same thing we have my
first million and the hook is ideas i'll
help you make money and get you get you
to your first million and what do you do
with that when you get there
i know that the people who are really
gonna love this because that's going to
fade like you get that hit yeah you get
the hit you get the hit what are you
going to be here a year from now
you should have already got that million
but you know by a couple years in or
whatever the people are going to stay
because damn these are just great
conversations i want to hang with these
guys yeah that's the only thing we do is
we create a fun conversation where
people wish they were i hope that like
there's a third seat in the studio
my goal is that somebody listening to
this was like damn i feel like i was in
that third right that was listen to a
real ass conversation between two people
not you talking to your book and me
talking my book but like right real
conversation by two people you were
curious and so i answered questions i
asked you a bunch of questions of stuff
i was curious about yeah they feel like
they got to be a part of a conversation
that was a little bit more entertaining
than whatever's going on in their world
that day like maybe their their real
life conversations that they weren't as
interesting sure my hope is that this
one is that they feel like they're in
that third seat that's like a win for me
with this and so cool hope people
enjoyed this i know this is appreciate
you coming out thanks for having me man
thanks for doing it in person because i
remember you reached out you're like
let's do a via zoom and i was like nah
we're doing this yeah sorry to sam yeah
we're pulling out for him yeah sam check
your dms bro
i'm in your dms doc
okay
cool thank you
[Music]
you